Hey there. As always, thank you for
being here, especially if this is your
first time with us, Adventist or
otherwise. So, once again, Dr. Dr. Jud
Lake is making the rounds this time on
the Adventist Pilgrimage podcast where a
few weeks ago he and others were invited
to engage some of the claims that I have
made regarding the Trinity and
Adventism's unique view.
Once again, our organizational
reputation is implicitly called into
question, which is why we are going to
yet again bring out the sources and take
as much time as needed to go over them
and show who is and isn't
misrepresenting things. When I commented
on their video, their response was,
"They weren't engaging in apologetics."
No, no,
no. They were just discussing Adventist
history.
So, we're going to start from the very
beginning, including their intro
segment, because we need to hear
something that is stated by Dr. Michael
Campbell from the start. This will be a
multi-part, more than likely three-part
series. So, we will get into part one
right now. Hey everybody, welcome to the
Adventist Pilgrimage Podcast. We uh have
got a pretty fun episode here today.
We've been going back and forth uh on a
couple of different topics and
directions. If you've been following us
for the last few months, uh you've heard
us giving some good uh thought to our
early pioneers, guys like GI Butler and
and some other ones like that. But
today, we're going to be going a little
bit more into the thinking of our
pioneers in terms of theology and in
terms of specifically the doctrine of
the trinity. Uh we've got lots of
different material on this. A couple of
different guests here are actually going
to be part of the conversation. Um the
eminent uh historian podcaster
extraordinaire Mr. Matthew Lucio is here
with us today as well as Dr. Jud Lake
coming to us from Southern Adventist
University uh just to kind of get all of
our heads together a little bit and to
talk about what the trinity has meant uh
within the 7th Adventist faith since the
early days on up to the present. Um, and
given that this is a larger topic than
even just the four people here, uh, this
is got a lot of a lot of people talking
already about it. Um, some of the folks
out on YouTube have been going back and
forth on these things and we're going to
be talking a little bit about some of
that because part of the goal of our
podcast is to both discover the unknown
parts of Adventist history, but also to
see how those parts of history apply to
the present. So, we're going to be
talking Trinity, Trinitarian, uh,
Pelagianism, and all these kinds of fun
theological topics today, but we just
kind of want to get things kicked off.
Michael, what how are we going to play
this one today? All those those those uh
fancy words is making starting to make
my head spin, so just want to say a warm
welcome to Matthew and Jud. Wow, we're
going to have a great time. I think so.
I think so. Thank you. Yeah. So, we're
going to look at some clips and we're
going to uh do a little bit of just kind
of brief commentary. Does this really
represent Adventism and what is the
historical context? So, we just want to
kind of uh just really look at these and
just try to really understand and make
sense of it.
All right. So, notice what Michael
Campbell said. They're going to look at
some clips and do a little bit of a
brief commentary to see
what does this really represent
Adventism and what is the historical
context. So gentlemen, when one of you
told me that you aren't doing
apologetics, you're only doing history.
No, you're not. You're engaging in
apologetics here. And this is about
signaling out that answering Adventism
is misrepresenting Adventism regarding
two things. the Trinity and two the SDA
pioneers on that subject. Now, like I
said, one of these gentlemen reached out
to me privately and because he requested
that I not say who, on principle, I
won't. But yes, you guys are engaging in
apologetics here, gentlemen. So, don't
act like you aren't and claim that I was
only an incidental part of this, that I
was only used to to accompany you guys
talking about Adventist history. No,
it's implicit in your claims that I'm
misrepresenting. don't know my stuff,
etc. You are implicitly claiming that we
are not a reliable organization and
source of information and people should
not listen to us. So to make sure that
this is crystal clear, if you make
claims about this organization and our
credibility and you bear SDA scholarship
credentials, you will be responded to
every single time. Okay, Dr. Lake, you
can keep making the rounds and we will
too.
You guys know that Answering Adventism
is making a splash and our impact is
only increasing. Our reach is growing.
And folks on this side that have been
here from the beginning know that I've
always said that this is a
marathon. Like I didn't train 10 years
for this to only run a couple miles,
fellas. But Dr. Campbell, I'm not sure
that all of you actually listened to the
full video if I'm being perfectly honest
with you. Because what we're about to
see is these four gentlemen actually
prove the entire thesis of the video
that they are
clipping. You all would have been
better, far better off actually
responding to our presentation on the
exact subject in focus, the Adventist
pioneers and their denial of the
Trinity. Not a presentation where the
thesis was whether or not the heavenly
trio is Orthodox
Trinitarianism. Two totally different
focuses and context.
Because what you all would have seen is
that the uh uh most of the claims that
you guys are about to bring up in this
stream regarding the pioneers and their
views I've stated myself in that exact
presentation. It's four hours
long. But to the audience, that's what
is stated as part of their goal with
this video. It wasn't just talking about
SDA history. It was to analyze my claims
and demonstrate that I'm misrepresenting
both Adventism and SDA history. Remember
this. All right, cool. And who's our
who's our clips coming from here?
Oh, we have uh we have some clips from a
channel called Answering Adventism. And
this first one is really going to set up
uh set up the crux of our discussion.
So, let's hit that one. You are not one
God because you have three individual
persons, which they're incorrectly
defining or defining it differently. All
right. Who are united in their mission,
so therefore it's one God. No, that's
not how it works. Okay. All right. This
is coming to us from Miles Christian and
making some claims um obviously about
Trinity talking a little bit about what
Adventism teaches uh how he thinks about
it and he's definitely of the opinion
that Trinity as Adventists have taught
it is not necessarily orthodox uh
according to other Christian
denominations. Now guys, obviously we've
had a chance to talk about this a little
bit, but just lead us into the
discussion a little bit either Dr. Lake,
Matthew or Michael. Um, what is the
doctrine of the trinity in the terms of
abist pioneers? Uh, has it always been
something that's been rock solid? Have
we worked through it? Have we evolved in
how we do we change terms? Like what
have we done with this topic?
Yeah, I think uh I think there's room
for a lot of clarification here because
you hear people talk about the avenist
pioneers as being u Aryan or
semi-ANA and you know we throw these
terms around and it you know I think
it's worth exploring what do we mean by
this and what did they actually believe
because the claim here is that
Adventists don't believe in the trinity
they believe in what he calls the
heavenly trio which is not a phrase he
invented of of course, but uh you saw in
his diagram there that we believe
basically basically in polytheism
in three gods who are just united by one
one purpose. And I don't know about you
guys, but when I heard that I thought,
"Wow, that's what I believe. That's good
to know." I I did, you know, I thought I
believed in the Trinity, but here I'm
finding out I don't actually believe in
that.
So, go figure. In fact, I don't I don't
really know any avenists who very few of
them maybe on Facebook, you know, like
the Facebook friends types who uh who
who don't believe in the Trinity.
Now, gentlemen, what's funny about this
is you guys played a 20 second clip
completely ignoring that the language I
used, even the analogy of what makes the
Adventist God one is coming from Jerry
Moon's Quest for a Biblical Trinity
paper, a document we proceeded to go
through at great length to support what
I was claiming. I mean, as a podcast
that centers around SDA history, I think
the chair of church history at Andrews
University, the flagship university, I
think it's a qualified source to site
from, but also it would have done you
all well to pay attention to the video
you were clipping to make sure you
understood the
thesis. Because again, this video wasn't
about the historical development of your
movement's understanding of God. It was
for Christians to explain to them where
the rub is between Christian Orthodoxy
and Adventism, which is precisely why it
took two and a half hours of diving into
specifics. But notice it was recognized.
My claim is that what the SDA church
calls the trinity is not orthodox
trinitarianism. And this was followed by
followed up by the question, has this
understanding changed? Has it evolved
over time, etc. Gentlemen, for
starters, it isn't according to other
denominations that you guys aren't
Orthodox. You aren't Orthodox because
you're out of sync with Christian
Orthodoxy, namely the
creeds. Because the creeds have
authority. The creeds have authority.
And what is set forth in the
creeds, namely the Nying creed, is the
baseline definition of the trinity. This
is an objective fact because the two
trinity and nice and creed are
intrinsically tied
together. Just do a study folks on the
history of the word because the word's
not found in scripture. That's not the
point. It's a summation statement to to
not have to be long-winded every time
you're trying to explain. It's a very
succinct way with one word to say, "Oh,
that so you believe that insert point
point without having to go through and
say all the points, which is why
definitions matter." And you can't come
along and do what the SDA church has
done and just on the surface be like,
"Well, we use all the same words, so
therefore you can't take umbrage with
what we're saying. It's essentially
trinitarian, as we're about to see." But
this is also insight into your guys'
misdefining of solos scriptor, which
also comes from Ellen White. Notice
folks, quote, "Those who oppressed these
followers of Christ called themselves
Protestants, but they objured the
fundamental principle of Protestantism,
the Bible and the Bible only as the rule
of faith and
practice." Nope, that's not solos
scriptor because the same individuals
that coined the phrase solos scriptor
believed that the creeds were a
barometer of Christian faith and
practice.
This is what solos scriptor means from
Charles Haj's systematic theology.
Quote, all Protestants agree in teaching
that the word of God as contained in the
scriptures of the Old and New Testaments
is the only
infallible rule of faith and practice.
Close
quote. Notice Ellen White left off the
word infallible.
Scripture alone is the only infallible
rule of faith and practice, not the only
rule outright because the creeds are a
rule of faith and practice. They're just
not God
breathed. But that doesn't mean that
because they're not God breathed,
they're incorrect or they're not
biblical. They're just not a part of
canon. They're not a part of what God
has spoken his own words. But God
absolutely led the church in the
formulation of denunciation of heresy
and everything that comes with that. But
the SDA church's own source documents
state that Ellen White's writings are
also
infallible. Individual Adventists can
disagree with that all they want, but it
doesn't change the facts. What is
contained in the creeds is not only
biblical, but it's foundational to the
Christian faith.
And it is the creeds that put you guys
outside of Orthodoxy, not some certain
denomination determining if you are or
not. But the question was asked if
anything has changed in Adventism as it
pertains to this
doctrine. Now folks, if one goes and
watches the stream that they're clipping
from, I not only recognize this, but
it's a core component of my objections.
It doesn't sound like these guys
actually listen to them closely enough
to catch why this is an issue on
something as fundamental as the
Trinity. This is a cardinal doctrine of
the Christian faith. Gentlemen, I
understand you guys don't see it that
way, which is precisely the point. This
is more important than esquetology and
the Sabbath and young earth creationism
and all the other distractions that
Adventists are obsessed with. We're
talking about which God you worship.
It's like everything else flows down
from
that. If you have the wrong God, the
rest of that stuff is null and void.
Which segus us to Matthew's uh comment
there that my chart puts forth that they
essentially believe in polytheism, that
they believe in three gods that are just
united in one person. And Matthew, that
is exactly correct, except you either
didn't fully watch as to why this was
being visually represented that way, or
you did and you're ignoring that for
some reason. We will circle back on my
chart towards the end when Jed Lake will
mention it as well. But then Matthew
followed up by rhetorically saying,
"Wow, that's what I believe as an
Adventist." And here we see the lack of
paying close enough attention. I'm on
record repeatedly saying,
gentlemen,
repeatedly that our criticisms are
levied at official SDA source materials
that bear the organizational stamp of
approval in some form or
capacity. It's not about you and your
own personal beliefs. I don't know
anything about you and your own personal
beliefs. That's not what that video had
anything to do
with. But friends, remember what my
objections were in the clip. What were
they? They only played like 20
seconds. They had nothing to do with
Matthew or any individual Adventist. My
objections were one, the SDA church
defines person
incorrectly, meaning not the same way
that Christians do. Because again,
remember the whole thesis of that video
was they don't believe the same thing
that Christians do organizationally.
And the second objection in that small
clip was the SDA church defines the
oneness of God
incorrectly. Now, it was demonstrated in
that video, but we're going to go even
deeper on this tonight and look at a
plethora and mountain of other sources
that weren't even brought up in that
video. We're also going to be looking at
Jerry Moon's paper yet again, the same
source that I used for the language that
was used in that clip. And this
highlights one of of my other primary
objections that that is a stone in my
apologetic
edifice. The SDA church uses Christian
language but does not define it the same
way. I mean, I'm on record saying this
over and over and over again.
So unless these gentlemen are going to
get into the specifics about definitions
and not just do the the superficial lip
service to using certain
words doesn't matter. And if definitions
don't matter then I can just start
saying I'm all sorts of things. I'm a
seventh day
Adventist except I don't go to church on
Saturday and I don't believe in young
earth creationism. I actually believe in
old earth. And every Adventist would say
you're not a Seventh Day Adventist. Yeah
I am because words don't matter. I can
just define them however I want. Right?
Notice a comment that this user left on
their
video. He wrote or she, whichever.
Quote, "I've been in the SDA church for
45 plus years now, now out. And the
issues that Miles answering Adventism
has raised are based on factual
historical information that this group
avoids." Miles makes clear he's not
attacking every individual member's
personal beliefs.
He's dealing with the published
documents by the founders and SDA
scholars. You guys go back and forth
between schoolyard tactics of simply
smearing Miles to straight out nonsense
on what the documents actually say. If
you have all the facts on your side,
then meet with Miles with uh a little
bit of a typo there. I just left it how
they wrote it. Then meet with Miles on a
neutral channel such as the SDA Q&A
where the documents can be reviewed and
you can explain how Miles is
incorrect. Either the SDA has the most
terrible history in knowing how to
communicate or the documents
straightforward reading is what was
intended. SDA church has a fundamental
belief that Ellen White is an authority.
She makes statements that are terrible
and anti-gosspel. Either defend them or
condemn them. But stop this enlightened
reading and reinterpretation of all the
words that make laughable claims. She
meant something totally different from
what she meant. Until you guys, SDA
church are willing to face the critical
review of your doctrines, you cannot be
taken
seriously. Now we can be sloppy is the
latest excuse. Ridiculous excuses from a
denomination that has all truth.
Folks, this is a person that's
listening. Thank you, friend. You get
it. And praise God for your freedom from
slavery in uh Adventist Egypt and that
God has added you to the convoy as Jesus
leads us to the better promised land.
But this is
spoton. Spot. And much of it will make
even more sense as we get further into
this. Nothing Matthew Lucio said
actually engages with my objections in
the clip that they played because my
source for both claims that the
personhood and oneness of God are
misdefined is based on claims from Pope
Ellen herself who claimed to have been
revealed this stuff in vision from God
himself which Jerry Moon even recognizes
and we look at in the stream that
they're clipping from. As for the claim
that only fringe SDAs on Facebook reject
the
Trinity, like Matthew, what a silly
claim. So now you're just going to throw
your own crew under the
bus. Adventists love doing this. You
know, we're not we're not those hyper
fringe, hyperconservative Adventists
anymore. You Oh, you mean like literally
all the people the Adventist church puts
on TV?
H again, this is a common approach
that's often employed. They know that
these people exist amongst their
movement. So they have to try and
distance themselves from them, but at
the same time they have the great
controversy theme, the God particle, the
theory of everything, the antidote to
theological division. They're not part
of Babylon. They were raised up as the
bastion of unity out of
Babylon. Mhm. Except for all those
Adventists on
[Laughter]
Facebook. You're kidding yourself, dude.
I know tons of Adventists that are
hopping on board either either recently
or have been for years and years and
years. They're in the camp where they
reject the heavenly trio. They reject
trinitarianism, too. And some of them
I've talked to actually recognize and
understand, yeah, what the Adventist
church has developed into it ain't
trinitarianism.
You know, these guys claim to be a part
of mainstream Adventism, which is
basically rule by
adopulum. And since they are the
majority, everyone else in the fringe,
you know, everyone else is a fringe
whacker doodle that doesn't represent
real Adventism. They all claim to be
real Adventism. I love how Peter Dixon
over on the SDA Q&A, he's on this like
scavenger hunt where he just brings all
these Adventists on there and he's like,
I'm trying to find like where can I find
what the real Adventist is? Everyone I
talk to, you all disagree. You all have
crazy beliefs that do not overlap. They
do not align. And yet, you all tell me
you're the real Adventist. I mean, what
an arc this movement is on. Folks, this
was a movement that raised up. And they
knew exactly who they were. They were
unashamed. They were bold. They had a
prophet. They had a spirit of prophecy.
And that was the hallmark that they were
the true group at the end that God
raised up. And now here we are, and it's
just this big tent. and we don't really
know what an Adventist is. It's just
what does an Adventist mean to you? And
yeah, okay, we saw this the last time we
responded to Jud Lake. If you recall, he
did the same thing. He made it seem like
my objections are only applicable to
some loose screwed Adventist, you know,
in his ascension gown off in the corner
somewhere. Gentlemen, again, you guys
allegedly have the theological God
particle, the theory of everything, the
mind of God, the antidote to theological
division. That's Herbert Douglas, not
me. Is he some fringe crackpot off in
the corner now
somewhere? It's not even just him saying
it. It's not like it's just in his
Heartbeat of Adventism book is in
Ministry magazine. The organization's
publishing this stuff. People are
signing off on this stuff, sending this
out to hundreds of people, thousands of
people. You guys aren't supposed to have
any theological division. That's
supposed to be a hallmark of Babylon,
which your movement is supposedly not a
part of, and you're the remnant out of
that. But let's see if they actually
engage with the objections I raised
before we look at the sources for my
objections. Okay. Okay. What what that's
that's interesting you say it that way
because that brings up the idea of if we
don't think of it that way, do we
somehow mean it differently? Like what's
what's the source here that we should be
talking about when it comes to our
doctrinal position?
Well, when you you look back in in
Adventist history and particularly Ellen
White, the emphasis has been on the
relational nature of the Trinity, the
Father, Son, and the Holy Spirit in
relationship. And Ellen White, that is
her emphasis on the relational trinity.
She's not attempting to to set forth the
trinity ontologically.
uh she's more focused in a practical way
on the work of the triune God in the
plan of
redemption. However, that does not
preclude or deny the oneness of
God. Okay. So, it was asked, do
Adventists mean something differently
when they say trinity? Yes, they do, as
we will see in a moment. But Dr. Like
everything you
said right there I say in the stream
that you listen to 20 seconds
of. I mean we looked at Jerry Moon's
footnotes where he cites who you're
citing from Fernando Canal and Fritz Guy
and their warning that if there's an
overemphasis put on the relational
aspect over and against the ontological
unity of the Adventist heavenly trio it
leaves the door open for tritheism.
However, this doesn't get you guys out
of
trouble because when the Christian
church when the Christian church talks
of the oneness of God in being, that
also includes one will, one energy, one
authority, one power, etc. For example,
and we just looked at these the other
night, by the
way. First, let's look at Augustine and
his day trinitat or on the trinity book
two. And you know, we had all sorts of
Adventists that commented on that video
saying all sorts of stuff about the
church fathers. And it's like it really
helps if you listen because I stated why
I was citing these individuals. There's
all sorts of people I could cite from on
this. I'm simply citing individuals that
do align with trinitarian theology
because it's not a spectrum. is not some
general term where you can have all
sorts of concepts of the trinity out
there which is what these guys are
trying to put forth because they have to
do that to then be able to hitch their
wagon to the term. It can't be hyper
specific and very specific which is
exactly why the term was coined dealing
with heresy and being very specific
about what the Christian church
believes. No, no, no. It has to be this
vague general thing where there can be
all sorts of concepts out there. So I am
citing the fathers here to simply show
you this isn't me just saying
this quote the purpose of all the
Catholic or universal commentators I've
been able to read on the divine books
referring to scripture of both
testaments who have written before me on
the trinity which God is has been to
teach that according to the scriptures
according to
what scripture
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit in the
inseparable equality of one substance
present a divine uni unity and are
therefore not three gods but one
God. Close
quote. Very clean cut. This was the
fourth century.
Trying God is not just one in a mission
and a purpose but also substant uh
substantally jumping up to the 8th
century John of
Damascus he explains what Christians
mean regarding the being or essence of
God. quote, "For there is one essence,
one goodness, one power, one will, one
energy, one
authority, one and the same, not three
resembling each other, but one with the
same movement of all three hypoasis,
meaning persons. Nor is there a
difference of will or intention or
energy or power or anything else that in
us gives rise to a real and complete
division. Therefore, neither do we call
the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit
three gods, but rather one God, the Holy
Trinity. Close
quote. That's what Christians mean. If
Adventists want to say, well, that's the
church fathers and well, you're just
proving the point, right? If you
disagree with them, you don't believe
the Christian position, which is the
entire
point. We it doesn't matter if you
reject them in this context. All that
does is prove the point because this is
the Christian belief. Whether you think
it's biblical or not is
irrelevant. It is biblical and it is
from scripture because these these terms
like hypostasis, us etc. are biblical
terms. But by one being we are referring
to the actual state of existence, the
essence. There's one power, one energy,
one authority, etc. Not three of those
that resemble one another, but one
singular being expressed through three
persons. A lot of people when they think
of the word being, they think of like a
human
being. But human is a descriptor of my
state of
existence. There's not three of those.
We will see how their system does not
comport with this in a moment. But he
said Ellen White's focus was on the
practical oneness in relation to the
Adventist heavenly trio and their role
in the plan of salvation. And Dr. Lake,
this is why you should have to use your
own word that you said to me. Listen
more
comprehensively. This is what you told
me. If I need to if I'm going to
critique Adventism, I need to to be more
comprehensively read. And then you held
up Salvation Contours of Adventology,
which I own.
because that is something I highlighted
in the video that you're responding to.
Again, first folks, notice from Jerry
Moon's paper, quote, "The conceptual key
that unlocks the puzzle of Ellen White's
developmental process regarding the
Godhead is the discovery that her
writings describe at least two distinct
varieties of trinitarian belief.
one based on scripture alone and one
based on scripture as interpreted
through the lens of Greek
philosophy. The same hermeneutic that
brought the immortality of the soul into
Christian theology. The concept of God
that is explicit in her writings
portrays the father, son, and holy
spirit as three eternal persons of
intellect, will and emotions who are
united in character, purpose, and love.
There's no conflict among them. No
working at cross purposes, no
competition, not even disagreement.
Thus, they are not three gods as in
polytheism or tritheism, but
one. And then again, he reiterates in
the conclusion of the paper, quote, the
change from Adventist rejection of the
traditional doctrine of the trinity to
acceptance of a biblical trinitarian
doctrine was not a simple reversal. When
James White denounced credle
trinitarianism in 1846, Ellen White
agreed with both his positive point that
the father and the son are two distinct
literal tangible
persons and his negative point that the
philosophical
trinitarianism held by many did
spiritualize away the personal reality
of the father and the son. Soon after
this, she added the conviction based on
visions that both Christ and the father
have bodily form, rejecting the teaching
of one trinitarian creed that God is
without body or parts. Close quote. So
notice he says that the key to unlocking
the puzzle of Ellen White's doctrinal
development in this area is what
discovery? that her writings describe at
least two distinct varieties of
trinitarian belief. And he compares the
Christian teaching with the Adventist
teaching by claiming that the Adventist
one is biblical, whereas what Christians
believe is philosophical and not
biblical. Total nonsense.
But he then explains that part of why
the SDA church rejects the language
found in the Nison creed is because the
Adventist teaching is that God the
Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit all have physical
forms, which is what they mean by the
term person when they say God is three
persons. That isn't what Christians
mean. And for those unaware, Moon talks
about Ellen's I saw the lovely Jesus
vision in his paper. This vision was
supposed uh supposed to be to confirm to
the movement that God indeed does have a
physical body because Ellen saw Jesus
and asked him this herself if God the
Father has a physical form like himself.
To which he supposedly said yes, but if
you were to behold it, you would cease
to exist. Which this shows, no, the SDA
organizational position isn't
trinitarian, which again was the entire
thesis of the video that you guys
clipped. You should have used the other
video, gentlemen. and criticized or
critiqued my my use of of walking
through Adventist history, but it
wouldn't have worked for your your
claims here because you're literally
just reiterating a bunch of things I've
said myself, which makes me wonder if
you've actually heard the
objections. And this is the problem I
have with these guys. Just own that you
guys mean something
different. Stop trying to act like you
believe the same thing we do when very
clearly you don't. I get so tired of the
silly runaround where they just use the
same words. They know they don't define
those words the same way, but then they
act offended when you point this
out. No, it's dishonest and it confuses
people. And instead of owning that, they
try and change the definition, making it
more broad and generalized when it's
actually very
specific, and then try and and say
their, you know, broadening of the term
is now the correct
definition. No, doesn't work that way.
But at the tail end of his claim, Dr.
Lake said, "The relational unity of the
heavenly trio does not preclude their
ontological
oneness." Dr. Lake, I I again, I
literally said that in the video you
guys are clipping from because you're
just paring Jerry Moon's
paper. But nevertheless, remember what
we read from Augustine and and John of
Damascus. By one being Christians mean
one will, one mode of existence, one
power, one authority, etc. These
scholars want us to believe that
Adventists believe in the same God as
Christians. So their authoritative
source documents should reflect this
then.
Correct? Spirit of Prophecy Volume 2,
page 9.
quote, "The Son of God was next in
authority to the great lawgiver. He knew
that his life alone could be sufficient
to ransom fallen man. He was of as much
more value than uh than man, as his
noble, spotless character and exalted
office as commander of all the heavenly
host were above the work of man. He was
in the express image of his father, not
in features
alone, but in perfection of character."
Close quote.
No, this isn't compatible with Orthodox
Trinitarianism. Jesus was not and is not
next in authority to God the Father, who
is the great
lawgiver. For starters, this is prior to
the
incarnation. And Ellen has Jesus
eternally subordinate to the Father,
which could get us down a whole trail of
talking about eternal functional
subordination and ESS and the
differences there, etc.,
which essentially says that the word has
eternally been subordinate or of a
possessing of less authority if you will
than the father. But on top of that,
that isn't co-equality and authority and
power
ontologically in the heavenly trio. The
father is a greater authority here.
Furthermore, this is one of her many
many statements where she says Jesus is
in the express image of God the father,
not just in features but character.
For those that are regulars, you know
that this is in reference to God the
Father having a physical body. Something
else we'll look at later with regards to
how they define
person. Another quote, we look at this
all the
time. Quote, God is the father of
Christ. Christ is the son of God. To
Christ has been given an exalted
position. He's been made equal with the
Father. All the councils of God are open
to his son. Close quote.
This is said in the
chapter where Ellen White is literally
discussing the way that the heavenly
trio is
one. After citing Hebrews 1 regarding
Jesus taking his throne, she says,
"Christ has been given an exalted
position and was made equal with the
father. There is no way to make this
compatible with the onlogical unity of
God." I am sorry, gentlemen.
You can try and say it's all this, you
know, cryptic and impossible to
understand without an approved SDA
handler there to hold our hand and walk
us through it, but it doesn't change the
facts. Christ was not given an exalted
position and made equal with the father.
Made equal,
gentlemen. The statement does not
comport with trinitarianism. Do you all
denounce this as
heretical? Is this not considered
authoritative? The woman codified in
your fundamental beliefs as divinely
inspired who received visions allegedly
confirming your guys's understanding in
not just this area but this area
included. And even if you want to try
and take it and go the route of no no,
she's talking there about after the
incarnation. That was only as a man that
he was exalted and made equal with God
the Father, which is one of the other
defenses given for this. Okay, here's
prior to the creation of the earth and
the incarnation.
very
beginning very beginning about the the
fall of of Satan in this pre-earth
origin
story chapter 1 very beginning quote
Satan in heaven before his rebellion was
a high and exalted angel next in honor
to God's dear son yeah
no his countenance like those of the
other angels was mild and expressive of
happiness his forehead was high and
broad showing a powerful intellect His
form was perfect, his bearing noble and
majestic. A special light beamed in his
countenance and shone around him
brighter and more beautiful than around
the other angels. Yet Jesus, God's dear
son, had the preeminence over all the
angelic host. He was one with the father
before the angels were created. Satan
was envious of Christ and gradually
assumed command which devolved on Christ
alone. Close quote.
For those that do not know, this is one
of the books that went on to be become
essentially the great
controversy. She says Satan was next in
authority to Jesus, meaning Satan was
higher in rank than the Holy Spirit, who
at this time they didn't even believe
was a person. Whoops. But she says the
Adventist Jesus was one with the father
before the angels were
around. Ah, so the Adventist Jesus was
there before the angels were. For those
that watch the funeral stream of the
pioneers, you know that at that time of
of writing this, their belief was that
Jesus was brought into existence, not
created, not created, but he had a
beginning. But he was brought into
existence at a point so far back that
it's practically eternal.
But just because that was the case
doesn't mean that the Adventist Jesus in
this narrative was ontologically equal
with God the
father. We already saw in part two of
the same
book. Jesus was next in authority to the
great
lawgiver. And here we see that she says
this is what triggered Lucifer to become
Satan and start the great controversy.
Command was
devolved to Christ from the father. The
word devolved means authority or power
given from a higher rank to a
subordinate lower ranking authority.
Which is why she then goes on in the
very next paragraph to describe this
further. We've looked at this about 5
million times. Quote, "The great creator
assembled the heavenly host that he
might in the presence of all the angels
confer special honor upon his son. The
son was seated on the throne with the
father and the heavenly throng of holy
angels was gathered around them. The
father then made known that it was
ordained by himself that Christ his son
should be equal with
himself. So that wherever was the
presence of his son, it was as his own
presence. The word of the son was to be
obeyed as readily as the word of the
father. His son he had
invested with authority to command the
heavenly
host. Especially was his son to work in
union with himself in the anticipated
creation of the earth and every living
thing that should exist upon the
earth. His son would carry out his will
and his purposes, but would do nothing
of himself alone. The father's will
would be fulfilled in him. Close quote.
Prior to the incarnation, before the
earth was even created,
supposedly the Adventist Jesus had
special honor conferred on him and he
was made equal with the father. He was
invested with the authority over the
angels of
heaven. He did not always possess this
authority. It's like to try and claim
that invested means he always had it.
Made equal means he always was. It's not
only desperate, but it's pathetic. And
that's the defense that the Adventists
try to give to this. It's so silly. They
try to retrofit their current church's
understanding which their own scholars
re re recognize. Well, what we believed
early on and what the pioneers believed
and there were some rocky roads and what
we believe now isn't what the pioneers,
you know, are actually saying. And
there's actually multiple understandings
of the Trinity and Ellen White's
writings. So you'll get Adventists that
won't own this that at this time, yes,
that is what they believed. Yes, this is
what they taught. Not this idea that,
well, when she says he was made equal,
it means he always possessed it. No,
you're retrofitting and trying to
anacronistically redefine
history. After this was given to Jesus,
he was to be obeyed as though it were
the father giving the command because
now they had the same authority. And
this made Satan jealous and he began to
rebel. Not at all compatible with the
onlogical unity of the one true God.
Fellas, I'm sorry. Again, John of
Damascus, John of Damascus is quote, put
forth what Christians mean by one being
that includes one authority, not a
greater and lesser
one to then invest into one making it
the same. But furthermore,
gentlemen, why why would God the Father
need to assemble all of the angels to
let them know this information when the
angels know that the triune God, Father,
Son, and Spirit is their
creator. And this brings us to yet
another crucial juncture that evidences
the SDA church is not
trinitarian. Because the other thing
that John of Damascus was getting at in
his quote was what is called the
doctrine of inseparable
operations which is the belief that
within the act of creation and
redemption, father, son, and spirit act
inseparably. Not like a team or or like
a band that cooperates together. You
know, like a band has different members
that all come together for a a specific
cause or goal and then cooperate
together to create an end goal or end
product like a
song. Now, the Triune God literally acts
as a single being. A team is not a
single being, but that's what your guys'
website says. And as we're going to see
in one of the later parts when we get
later into their video and probably part
two, you're going to see how they try
and and use this silly excuse that,
well, you know, theologians didn't put
our website together and I know we have
damnable blasphemous heresy on our
website, but cut us some slack,
man. Just crazy.
But in your guys's great controversy
paradigm, God the Father called all the
angels together to let them know that
Jesus, who's also their creator, was now
to be obeyed as though it was if the
father were giving the
command, even though the one true God is
father, son, and spirit. All
right? It's fine if you guys want to de
dismiss all of that as tech uh, you
know, all of that technical stuff, you
know, as Greek and pagan philosophy or
what have you, but it doesn't change the
facts.
doesn't change the facts. Later on in
the same
book, quote, "Satan again rejoiced with
his angels that he could by causing
man's fall pull down the Son of God from
his exalted
position." He told his angels that when
Jesus should take fallen man's nature,
he could overpower him and hinder the
accomplishment of the plan of salvation.
Close quote.
So, Satan allegedly rejoiced when man
fell because he knew this allowed him to
pull down Jesus from what? His exalted
position, which as we just saw is what
triggered his jealousy in the first
place, leading to the great controversy
allegedly even starting. Again, Darkness
Before Dawn, page two. quote, "Instead
of seeking to make God supreme in the
affections and allegiance of his
creatures, it was Lucifer's endeavor to
win their service and homage to himself
and coveting the honor which the
infinite father had bestowed upon his
son." This prince of angels aspired to
power which it was the prerogative of
Christ alone to wield." Close quote.
Over and over and over again, the same
thing is being said. Jesus was bestowed
with honor from an infinite who father.
The father's the infinite one. And he
bestowed honor on the adventist Jesus
which led to Lucifer becoming jealous
and coveting that honor since he was
next in authority to Jesus and he wanted
to be the one that was
exalted. But Ellen White claimed to be
shown this stuff from
God. Not that this is just some
beautiful sounding novel that's just,
you know, a supplement for people to
feel loveydovey about the Adventist
Jesus. No, this is all allegedly a peak
behind the curtain to what was going on
in heaven before the earth was created.
And it allegedly gives the SDA church
special insight into the fabric of
reality at a level that no one else
has. You guys do mean something
different when you use the word trinity.
You guys do mean something different
when you say three persons.
which has been my entire contention all
along. But Dr. Lake, everything you said
so far, I state in the video you guys
clipped, nothing that you said disproves
the two objections that you guys heard
me mention. To reiterate, one, person is
defined differently, which is a major
issue. And two, the oneness of God is
incorrectly defined. And even with
Fernando Canal's caveat that it doesn't
preclude a oneness of ontology, well,
now you have problems because that's
going to contradict your
prophetus when she's talking about a
greater and a lesser authority and
authority being devolved and given and
exaltation and all this stuff. It's like
on the one hand, you guys want to give
lip service to orthodoxy, but at the
same time, you're stuck having to uphold
the great controversy fiction. You can't
have it both
ways. You can't have it both ways.
You either embrace orthodoxy, which is
biblical, and reject Ellen White and the
great controversy lie, or you defend and
stand by Ellen White and reject
orthodoxy and what scripture teaches.
You can't have it both ways. The two do
not fit
together. And as Jerry Moon also points
out in the paper that we looked at, the
Adventist development in understanding
the Godhead came by way of Ellen White
and her visions.
quote, "In previous research, I have
traced the development of the Adventist
doctrine of God from opposition to the
Trinity doctrine as traditionally
formulated to acceptance of the biblical
concept of one God and three persons.
I've also traced the clear progression
in Ellen White's visions from 1850
onward, showing that her visions
gradually formed her concept of God
until 1890 or until by
1898. When she published Desire of Ages,
she held a trinitarian
concept. Close
quote. It wasn't Bible study that formed
her view. It was supposed visions.
So Christian, don't fall for it when
they claim that all their doctrines come
from exhaustive, you know, deep Bible
study. They're just, oh man, they just
they study the Bible so much more than
everyone else. They're just, wow, it's
just incredible. Just no one else
actually reads the Bible. They really
read the Bible. And because of that,
they were rewarded with all this extra
light that God gave them through Ellen
White, who could confirm the things they
were studying in scripture.
Moon admits in this paper that the
current Adventist
understanding, the current understanding
was informed by this doctrinal
development that he traces in the paper
and it was influenced by Ellen's alleged
visions. And what does he say by
1898? That she held to a
trinitarian concept.
not the trinity but a trinitarian
concept. These guys essentially admit
and and go on to say this themselves
later
on. And since this movement likes to
appeal to Protestantism in this area,
just to really make sure our bases are
covered, let's look at some uh sources
with regard to this that show the
Protestant response to sex like
Adventism. Notice John Calvin here. This
is from his French confession. He
writes, quote, "These holy scriptures
teach us that in this one soul and
simple divine essence whom we've
confessed, there are three persons, the
Father, Son, and the Holy Spirit. The
Father, first cause, principle, and
origin of all things. The Son, his word,
and eternal wisdom. The Holy Spirit, his
virtue, power, and efficacy. The Son
begotten from eternity by the Father.
The Holy Spirit proceeding eternally
from them both. the three persons not
confused, but distinct and yet not
separate, but of the same essence, equal
in eternity and
power. And in this we confess that which
has been established by the ancient
councils, and we detest all sex and
heresies which were rejected by the holy
doctors such as St. Hillary, St.
Athanasius, St. Ambrose, and St. Serill.
Close
quote. Amen.
Superbased take by John Calvin. Equal in
power and authority. Not Jesus being
given more authority and power to be
made equal with the father. No,
Adventists are not heirs of the
reformation in any way, shape or fashion
from the Belgic
confession. Article nine, the scriptural
witness of the trinity. This is the tail
end of the article which summarizes what
was said previously. Quote, "This
doctrine of the holy trinity was always
or has always been maintained in the
true church from the time of the
apostles until the present against Jews,
Muslims and certain false Christians and
heretics such as Marian, Monty, Praius,
Selius, Paul of Samoda, Aras and others
like them who were rightly condemned by
the holy
fathers. And so in this ma in this
matter we willingly accept the three
ecumenical creeds the apostles nyin and
aanation as well as what the ancient
fathers decided in agreement with
them always
maintained did not need reworked or
rethought in the 19th century by a bunch
of sectarians who up and deemed
themselves to be the true return you
know to the
bible and then had a woman who received
a bunch of visions to steer their
development of a trinitarian concept.
concept. And well, God showed her early
on one concept. And well, as she started
to better develop over time, there was a
different concept that he showed her.
And man, the Adventist God is the most
abysmal communicator in the
world. The Trinity is fundamental to the
Christian faith as defined in the
Petristic era, not your own personal
definition informed by a worldview that
was concocted in the 19th century. It's
like you don't just get to up and use
the term and then entirely redefine it.
39 articles Anglican confession quote
there's but one living and true God
everlasting without body parts or
passions basically just meaning that
God's emotions are not like you can be
in a good mood in the morning and then
you know an hour later you're in a
horrible mood and then you're in an okay
mood and then in a bad mood again etc.
God's not like that. That's what it
means by
passions of infinite power, wisdom, and
goodness, the maker and preserver of all
things, both visible and invisible. And
in unity of this Godhead, there be three
persons of one substance, power, and
eternity, the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Ghost. The Son, which is the word
of the Father, begotten from everlasting
of the Father, the very and eternal God,
and of one substance with the Father,
took man's nature in the womb of the
blessed virgin of her substance, so that
two whole and perfect natures, that is
to say, the Godhead and
manhood, were joined together in one
person, hypothetic union, never to be
divided, whereof is one Christ, very
God, and very man, who truly suffered,
was crucified, dead, and buried to
reconcile his father to us and to be a
sacrifice not only for original guilt
but also for actual sins of men.
one power, no authority given to the son
from the father like in the great
controversy
narrative which is more authorative more
authoritative than any individual SDA
scholar. But also notice something else
that's vital in this folks. The 39
articles speak of the hypothetic union.
The two natures of Christ united in the
single person 100% man 100% God to never
be divided mixed etc. This is coming
from the Nying creed.
Adventists do not teach this about
Christ. And here's
why. They claim he set his divine nature
aside while on earth. And we've looked
at this before. This is from the
paragraph on the page where they bold
the letters. In the paragraph before
saying this, Jesus is 100% man, 100%
God.
Then literally in the next paragraph
they say Philippians 2 6-8 says that
even though Jesus is God, he set his
divine nature aside and took on human
nature. So they give the kosis
interpretation of Philippians 2 which is
incompatible with the hypothetic union
after claiming it's like they inherited
this sort of thinking from Ellen White
because that's exactly what she would
do. She'll say one thing and then
literally the next paragraph she just
contradicts herself.
But even with that aside, what does the
SDA church teach about
death? The Adventist Jesus set his
divine nature aside. He was only a man
while on
earth. And what does the Adventist
church teach about
death? That you essentially cease to
exist. Your properties of humanity such
as consciousness entirely cease. You
only exist as a memory in the mind of
God who remembers your character
perfectly to then infuse it into a new
body that he will make for the righteous
in the
future. So when the Adventist Jesus
died, he ceased to exist for three days.
He was only a man on earth. He had no
conscious activity for three days, which
flies in the face of the hypothetic
union. There's no division at that
level. You would have had a division in
the hypothetic union. So even on that
page where they try to pay lip service
to
it, they don't see how it doesn't even
comport with the rest of their
system. Like Adventist theology, folks,
is not an integrative system. It It's
not a system where the people that
concocted this up actually understood
how certain doctrines impact other
doctrines. It's just this big grab bag
of all over the place. And then when
they get criticized and get criticism,
oh, they scramble and they come up and
like they try and put a bunch of
band-aids and fix things and tape it up.
Okay, now we fixed it. And they've done
that in like 500 areas. And now it's
just even worse than it was when they I
mean the people in the movement who say
we need to go back to the pioneers.
Yeah, you do. You do if you want to be
consistent. They're more consistent than
present day Adventism, which is a mess.
I mean, it was a mess back then, but
it's even worse now because they try and
talk out of both sides of their mouth.
But in harmony with this same use of
Philippians 2, this is after the desire
of ages,
gentlemen. After the desire of
ages, which Jud Lake, Jerry Moon, and
others appeal to to say it was by that
point the Adventist church had
everything sorted out.
Quote, "The eternal word gave
himself, he did not aspire to be equal
with God. Did not meditate a usurpion of
the throne of the universe. See
Philippians
2. But he emptied himself, gave himself
then and there for sinners. He took the
form of a servant, becoming an angel
among the angels that he might redeem
angels." Think what?
But they would
not. And when they rejected the
righteousness and life so freely
offered, he descended lower still to
those duped by Satan, fallen man,
stooping even to death that he might
redeem of the fallen all who desired to
be redeemed and vindicate to the
universe to all eternity the character
of
God. That was the work of the word of
God, the eternal logos. when he became
Michael the Archangel, when he became
Jesus the man of Nazareth, when he was
anointed the the Christ, when he died
our sacrifice on
Calvary. Yet during all this time, the
host of evil with all the baleful,
deceptive, cruel devices of sin were
hurled against him, that God's character
might be marred, that the great
vindicator redeemer might fall. Close
quote.
Ah, so the Adventist Jesus took on an
angelic
nature, not just the role of a
messenger. You know, they love to say,
"No, no, no. The Adventist church has
never taught that Jesus was an angel,
just that he was an angel in the sense
of the term the angel means messenger."
Yeah. No. They're saying here in Signs
of the Times, an angelic nature.
He took on an angel nature and became
Michael the
archangel. And he did this allegedly to
try and save the angels that rebelled,
but they rejected him. So then he took
on the nature of a man seeking to redeem
humanity. And in doing so, like we saw
from the website, he set his divine
nature aside that he received in the
pre-earth exaltation that we saw
earlier.
And all of this is tied to the great
controversy narrative of the Adventist
Jesus seeking to silence Satan's
accusations against the ten commandments
etc. Again a year later same
publication quote he talking about Jesus
took the nature of angels to repeat the
first step then in his humiliation in
laying aside his divine
nature was to put on the nature of
angels. And thus it is that we have
Jesus brought to view as Michael the
archangel, the commander of the host of
heaven, the captain of the host of the
Lord. And as such, the armies in heaven
follow him. When he became an
angel, he bore a fitting
name. Even as when later he became man,
his name befitted the nature which he
took by virtue of his birth into our
human family. That name was Emmanuel,
God with us. His name as an
angel is Michael which signifies the one
who is like
God. Whatever the name that he takes in
crushing sin and rebellion, in redeeming
the lost and in restoring humanity to
the universe or harmony to the universe,
that name must indicate that God is in
him and with him on the very plain and
the very nature of the class of beings
to whom he is sent. By living the god
life on the plane of angels of which
Satan was one although fallen he could
neutralize the force of Satan's
accusations. Thus when he became an
angel the fact must not be lost sight of
that he was God with the angels yet
living on their plane possessing their
natures. And this thought he preserved
in the name that he bears as an angel.
Close quote. I I mean,
come on, man.
Wow. Same thing is said here. And this
demonstrates that even when this
organization uses the word God, they
don't mean the same thing Christians
do. That as an angel with an angelic
nature, Jesus was still God on that
plane.
And they utilize the same interpretation
of Philippians 2, like I said, that we
just saw on their website to this day to
try and support this heresy in this
issue of Signs of the Times, just like
they did in the previous
year. On top of that, as if that isn't
bad enough, from the Seventh Adventist
belief, fundamental beliefs
book,
quote, Jesus asserted his omnipresence
with the asurances, lo, I with you
always, even to the end of the age.
Matthew 28:20. And where two or three
are gathered together in my name, I am
there in the midst of them. Matthew
18:20. Although his divinity has the
natural ability ability of omnipresence,
the incarnate Christ has voluntarily
limited himself in this respect. He's
chosen to be omnipresent through the
ministry of the Holy Spirit. John
14:16-18. Close
quote. So the Adventist Jesus isn't
truly omnipresent. By taking on the
nature of humanity, he limited himself
in this capacity. And of course, this is
ultimately coming from Ellen White.
Quote, "The Holy Spirit is Christ's
representative, but divested of the
personality of humanity and independent
thereof. Cumbered with humanity, Christ
could not be in every place
personally. Therefore, it was for their
interest that he should go to the Father
and send the Spirit to be his successor
on earth. No one could then have any
advantage because of his lo of his
location or his personal contact with
Christ. By the spirit, the savior would
be accessible to all. In this sense, he
would not he would be nearer to them
than if he had not ascended on high.
Close
quote. So, she contradicts herself here
because like Jerry Moon recognized in
his paper and we've looked at before,
she claimed the Holy Spirit is just as
much a person as the son and the father.
meaning he has a physical tangible form
that looks like a human. Close quote or
or begin quote
sorry. In the 1890s when she became
convinced of the individuality and
personhood of the Holy Spirit, she
referred to the Holy Spirit in literal
tangible terms much like those she had
used in 1850 to describe the father and
the son. For instance, addressing the
church at Aenddale College in
1899, she declared, "The Holy Spirit,
who is as much a person as God is a
person, is walking through these grounds
unseen by human eyes. He hears every
word we utter and knows every thought of
mind." Close quote.
But in Desire of Ages, she claims that
the Holy Spirit is Christ's
representative in his physical absence
and is divevested of personality of
humanity. The same thing found in the
fundamental belief book. None of this
stuff, gentlemen. None of it comports
with trinitarianism. And this is only
scratching the surface for the sake of
time. And until you guys are ready to
denounce the signs, sign of the time,
signs of the times, Ellen White, your
own church's website, and a mountain of
other primary source documents, this
problem will persist, and I will
continue to make the claims that I have
for myself. Um, the Trinity is something
that was always very clear in my mind
from the very onset of my Christian
experience.
Um, I grew up in the United Methodist
Church and I remember uh singing the
doxology, praise, father, son, and holy
spirit. And so when I became an
Adventist as as a young man, um it just
it was a concept that that while I
certainly couldn't explain in all its
details and nuances, it it was there.
And as I have grown in my Adventist
experience and study of scripture and
Ellen White and just thinking about this
great subject, uh the idea that um I
would be a tritheist is just something I
could not comprehend. Um I've always
understood the oneness of God. In fact,
that's probably the best way to describe
it is is this basic
trinitarianism at its very basic level.
You have the oneness of God and the
threeness of God in in a divine tension
relationship. God God is one one God.
Yeah. But God is three.
Yeah. Three persons, one being.
Dr. Lake, it's fascinating that you
mentioned growing up in the Methodist
church and understanding the Trinity
because of that.
Like we looked at in the video Dr. Lake
is responding to again from Jerry Moon's
paper documenting the doctrinal
development of the Adventist heavenly
trio in contrast to orthodox
trinitarianism. Quote in maintaining
that the father and the son are two
distinct literal tangible persons. James
White certainly did not doubt that God
is spirit. John 4:24. But he insisted
that those spiritual beings, Christ and
the father are nevertheless divine
persons who have a literal tangible
existence. They are neither unreal nor
imaginary. Meaning if they don't have a
physical body, they must be unreal and
imaginary. The trinitarian creeds he
knew of made God so abstract,
theoretical, and impersonal that God was
no longer perceived as a real, caring,
loving being. For example, one
trinitarian creed that early Adventists
quoted fairly often was that of the
Methodist Episcopal Church, Ellen
White's Church of Origin. That creed
says in part, "There's but one living
and true God, everlasting without body
and
parts." This the early Adventists
vigorously refuted, citing several
biblical passages that portrayed God as
having both body and parts. Close quote.
Folks, Ellen White's understanding and
teaching on the heavenly trio was
different than what she was taught in
the Methodist church. Her along with all
the po
pioneers, they didn't understand divine
simplicity, another uh key aspect that
we're going to look at later regarding
trinitarianism. And they didn't
understand what the Nying creed means
when it says God is not made up of body
or parts. That he's a simple being,
meaning he's not 50% love, 20% holy, 5%
almighty, etc. Nor can he be pieced
apart like a human who, you know, I have
two ears, two eyes, a mouth, a nose.
These are all composite pieces that when
brought together make a human being.
God's not like that. You can't piece God
apart like
that. But Dr. Lake, Ellen White was
allegedly shown this stuff from the one
true God himself, who showed her that
the Methodist teaching was
wrong. Yet that's what you appeal to for
your own personal understanding.
She literally reports. Well, we're going
to get to it here in a moment. Ellen
White's doctrinal development is what
informs the SDA church's official
position, not yours. Moon continues in
the same paper.
Quote, in 1850, she reported, "I've
often seen the lovely Jesus that he is a
person." There's that word
person. I asked him if the father was a
person and had a form like himself.
Instead, Jesus, I'm in the express image
of my father's person. Thus, her visions
confirmed, her visions confirmed what
her husband had written in 1846 that the
father and the son are two distinct
literal tangible persons. The visions
also disprove to her mind the claim of
the Methodist creed that God is without
body or parts. Thus, these early visions
steered her developing view of God away
from credle
trinitarianism, though they offered
nothing directly contrary to her later
statements of what I've called biblical
trinitarianism. Close
quote. So, Dr. Leg's prophetus claims
she was shown God the Father and Son
both have physical bodies by nature,
which is what they mean by the term
persons. But notice Moon also points out
that these visions, not the Bible, but
visions, steered her developing view of
God
away from orthodox
Trinitarianism. So, Dr. Lake, if you
embrace what Methodists do about the
Trinity, you have a serious problem here
because you guys claim Ellen White's
function and role was that of
confirmation. Your pioneers were
studying the Bible, we're told. They
claimed the Nying creed was wrong and
that they could point to all sorts of
passages where God was shown to have
both body and parts. And then to confirm
this that they were correct, Ellen
supposedly received a vision and direct
access to speak straight to Jesus face
to face where she asked him and he told
her this was true which gave you guys
the divine confirmation your movement
that the nine creed is incorrect. He
said basic trinitarian trinitarianism in
its very basic level. You have the
oneness of God and the threeness of God
in a divine tension
relationship. This is why the creeds
exist. Now that isn't trinitarianism.
Put simply. Put simply, the triune God
is one being that exists in uh as three
co-eternal and co-equal persons, namely
the father, son, and the spirit.
The triune God is one being that exists
as three co-eternal co-equal persons
namely the father the son and the
spirit and defining those terms God
being
person
foundational not a divine a divine
tension relationship at first heard I'm
like what are you talking about dude
It's like, who even knows what that's
supposed to
mean? And I like Dr. Lake. He's a nice
guy. It's been a while since I've I've
really seen him or talked to him, but
it's just like he he has a a a running
track record of just saying these sort
of like theological word salads. It's
just like what? Like when he said Jesus
is was the it's like the story of the
great controversy, he said is the is
really the true underdog story.
Like
what? Jesus was the underdog to Satan.
Wow.
Wow. But this is the irony of all of
this, gentlemen. The entire purpose of
Nika was to clarify with precise
specificity what Christians mean by
these terms because that's what was
needed. The heretics were using all
similar language.
It's like folks just study the second,
third, fourth
centuries. Just study. They were all
using the same language. So specificity
was needed to really make clear what's
being said because it matters. Not just
that you're saying all the right
words. But they want to try and say,
well, the trinity is really just a
general term and they basically are
trinitarian because of that. No, totally
backwards. My entire point has been that
definitions matter, not simply using the
right words. And all we got here was
more of that. Dr. Lake forcefully
saying, you know, God is one, but God is
three. That tells us nothing. That
doesn't tell us
anything. And if you guys don't want to
hear the charge of tritheism, then get
more specific and stop just using
Christian language. Define for the
audience what you guys mean by the words
person and being and
God. But then notice the final statement
there from Matthew. Three persons, one
being.
friend Matthew, this is where you come
to a fork in the road. Okay,
quote, "Before the entrance of evil,
there was peace and joy throughout the
universe. All was in perfect harmony
with the creator's will. Love for God
was supreme. Love for one another
impartial. Christ the Word, the only
begotten of God, was one with the
eternal father, one in nature, in
character, and in purpose, the only
being in all the universe that could
enter into all the councils and purposes
of God.
By Christ the Father wrought in the
creation of all heavenly beings. By him
were all things created that are in
heaven, whether they be thrones or
dominions or principalities or powers.
Colossians 1:16. And to Christ equally
with the Father, all heaven gave
allegiance. Close quote. It's the great
controversy. Page
493. Jesus was the only being in all the
universe that could enter into all the
councils and purposes of God.
So the father's a distinct being and the
son is a distinct being. Furthermore,
when Adventists try and point here to
claim, see, she said they have the same
nature. Yeah. Well, we just saw where
this organization's claiming that Jesus
had an angelic
nature. So the father and the holy
spirit also have angelic natures. I
guess total mess of confusion.
This is why I'm so harsh on this
organization,
gentlemen, because we're supposed to
believe that all of this is divinely
inspired. Selected messages, book three,
page 122, paragraph 2. This book is
supposed to be great controversy. Is one
of the books that's supposed to be
barricaded by a thus sayeth the
Lord. It allegedly bears the stamp of
the one true God himself. Yet, this
whole narrative, specifically this part
of the story line, completely
contradicts who the one true God is.
Jesus wasn't given access to some
special councils that he didn't
previously have access
to. Yet, this is what she claims was
part of what he gained in his exaltation
to be made equal with the father, which
made Lucifer
jealous. Signs of the Times 1900 after
Desire of
Ages supposed to all be ironed out by
this
point. Quote, Christ is the
pre-existent, self-existent son of God.
In speaking of his pre-existence, Christ
carries the mind back through dateless
ages. Close quote. Yet,
no,
no, Christ is not
self-existent. That's what the term
being encompasses, mode of
existence. Father, son, and spirit are
the single
self-existence. Yet, Ellen White says
Jesus is self-existent, which would mean
that he has his own being, the father
has his own being, etc.
Hebrews 1 explains Jesus is the radiance
of the
father similarly to what light is from
the
sun. The light proceeds from the sun and
is substantively the same. But it can't
exist apart from the source. So think of
Jesus like the light rays proceeding
from the source, the
sun. You can't have the rays without the
source. The rays are not self-existent
by
themselves. But even though the sun is
the source of the light, the sun cannot
be the sun without the light proceeding
um or the light that is produced also
being present and proceeding from it to
be what it is.
So the father's the son in this analogy
here the su
n the son the s o n the word is the
radiance of the father but the father
cannot be the father without the son
think about that how how are you a
father
without in this case the son you
wouldn't be both are dependent upon one
another a father isn't a father without
the son which is why god the father has
eternally been a
because his son eternally proceeds from
him. And this is why the Nying creed
says light from light, God of true God.
And the church fathers had a far better
understanding of scripture than Ellen
White and the SDA pioneers. You guys are
free to disagree with that. But the
point remains the same. The SDA
organization does not mean the same
thing Christians do in this area.
Period.
speaking about the heavenly trio at an
Adventist baptism in 1906 after the
desire of
ages. Quote, "Here is where the work of
the Holy Ghost comes in. After your
baptism, you're baptized into the na in
the name of the Father and the Son and
of the Holy Ghost. You are raised up out
of the water to live henceforth in
newness of life, to live a new life. You
are born unto God and you stand under
the sanction and power of the three
holiest beings in heaven who are able to
keep you from
falling. You are to reveal that you are
dead to sin. Your life is hid with
Christ and God close quote beings
plural. again in the Australian Union
Conference record in 1907 after the
desire of
ages. Quote, "Those who have by baptism
given to God a pledge of their faith in
Christ and their death to the old life
of sin have entered into covenant
relation with God. The three
powers of the Godhead, the Father, Son,
and Holy Spirit are pledged to be their
strength and their efficacy or
efficiency in their new life in Christ
Jesus." Close quote.
Three powers plural. No, gentlemen. I'm
sorry. Your organization's not
trinitarian because this is an
authoritative
source possessing more authority than
any of you guys
individually. Your guys's own private
views, etc. are not what this platform
is about, nor what the video is about
that you clipped.
And Ellen White holds more authority
than you guys and your own private views
which contradict her allegedly desp uh
divinely inspired
ones. So you either need to admit she
was
wrong, which poses a whole new set of
problems, or you need to agree with her
and just own and admit that the Trinity
has a very distinct definition and you
guys disagree with it. Use your own term
like heavenly trio.
Yeah. And I think it's important to note
there's a couple of the early church
heresies. So tritheism is this idea of
having like three separate gods. You
know, this sort of polytheistic kind of
approach that there's a whole bunch of
different gods. And um Adventists I'
I've never run across where Adventists
believe that. Maybe there's some
exception out there somewhere, but
that's never been normative for the
church. And where there have been
concerns about the trinity, it's only
usually because of the term trinity with
Catholic association of the term trinity
and that would develop a process because
of the 19th century. But but you look at
the earliest himnels of our church, they
have the doxology praise father, son and
holy ghost. You see very clearly that
there were hymns worshiping um the three
divine persons but that they were also
one. And so this theological concept
would take some time to explore and
understand as many other ideas have
throughout our Adventist history, our
Adventist past. Uh but that should not
surprise us that uh our church pioneers
would grow in their understanding and
clarification. But in terms of three
divine persons and then the central idea
of them being one, that that's an idea.
Yeah. Yeah, definitely. And I you know I
think uh what we're trying to describe
here is uh really a progression in
Adventist history in the very very
beginning and it's really important to
understand I think the cultural context
out of which Adventism emerged and that
is this restorationist movement and for
Adventists you know really that meant
let's go back to the absolute basics
let's not take church history for
granted let's try and start over and
that is a personally I find that to be a
very beautiful idea, right? Let's try
and start over 1,800 years after Christ.
Also, I think we can look back and say
also a little bit naive, right? It's
hard to just chuck out everything and
start over. And they started over on
some things like the like the the
Godhead, like the Trinity that I wish
they wouldn't start over on. You know,
some things you can you can build upon.
But I but I think I can appreciate the
the intention there. And so, the idea
was let's start over. Let's not take
anything for granted. They discovered
Sabbath, right? They rediscovered
Sabbath from the from the Seventh Day
Baptists. And this was this was the
fruit of that of that willingness to go
back to the Bible and start over. It's
what did we miss? What lies beneath the
tradition that we have inherited that
that maybe should be brought back to the
forefront like Sabbath and like some of
these other ideas. Now, as a part of
that process, of course, that that also
means kind of uh getting a softer on on
some topics we that later on, I think we
firmed up on, like the Trinity. And so,
I think it's important to understand
that that cultural background of what
the pioneers were trying to do.
They just wanted to go back to
scripture.
All right. So, Michael Campbell said,
"Triism has never been normative for the
church." Well, that just begs the
question, Dr. Campbell, because I never
claimed
this. If you guys watched the video, I
said
functionally, I've always said this,
functionally, the organization is
tritheistic, because it is. That's the
whole reason I brought up that visual
and that chart because I'm utilizing the
definitions put forth by scholars in
your own
movement in conjunction with Ellen's
visions. You guys have three beings that
are united in a mission together and
since they aren't ever at cross
purposes, they're one God. That's what
Jerry Moon tells us. That's not the
trinity. But you guys try and call it
such because you keep boiling things
down to general terms. He kept saying
they're divine persons. We believe
they're divine persons. We we sang about
father, son, and holy spirit. Gentlemen,
that doesn't make you trinitarian. Just
because you use those
words like do you not understand that
Aras talked about the father, son, and
spirit. Selius talked about the father,
son, and
spirit. This idea of just this general
like look, we use all these same words.
You guys mean something entirely
different.
I'm going to keep saying this like at
maybe at maybe the 10 and1th time it'll
click and a light bulb will go
off. The the core issues that I've I've
brought up haven't been
addressed. Maybe I wasn't clear enough.
So, I'll say it
again. What you guys call the Trinity
isn't.
Not that it's some conspiracy where I'm
saying you guys are lying and secretly
you believe in tritheism but you don't
want to tell
people. No, it's how you guys define
things which we haven't gotten any
clarification
on. But then he said it shouldn't be
surprising that the SDA pioneers grew in
their understanding of this doctrine.
No, actually that should be very
surprising. That should be like super
surp I mean major red flags. Red flag
alert. Because when you come along, 1900
years later claiming to be raised up by
the one true God as his last day people
with a unique and special mission and
message that no one else
has, but you don't even believe in the
one true God. Uh yeah, that's a problem.
The pioneers idea of starting over and
just going back to the Bible, like
Matthew pointed out, really meant
embracing a bunch of ancient heresy that
God had already settled within the first
few centuries of the church's history.
Because the Adventist pioneers were a
bunch of theological noviceses that
didn't understand Christian theology 101
and had zero business doing what they
did.
Which is why we're now left to believe
that the true God used a group of people
that actively were hostile toward him,
rejected him as being a pagan deity and
concept, and formed an idol in their own
minds and likeness to spread to
multitudes of people and preach
damnation on people who didn't accept
it. But then 120 years down the road,
they straightened up and now allegedly
believe in this one true God that
Christians believe in for 1900 years
before this movement was even a blip on
the radar. So it just came full circle.
Apparently God raised up a bunch of
heretics who didn't believe in the one
true God to then bring that movement of
people to eventually just accept what
Christians have always believed.
Anyways,
okay. It's like this is reason
13,01 why I could never be an Adventist.
It's like one must suspend critical
thinking to do
so. But Matthew, it's not a beautiful
idea to try and start the Christian
faith over 1900 years removed from Jesus
and the
apostles because restorationism is
actually sectarianism which is not
beautiful at all. Jesus hates
it. But he also talked about the
restorationist mindset of the pioneers
and that it led them back to the Bible
and they found doctrines that had been
missed. Right? And Matthew says
who? Says
who? Why are you right and the pioneers
wrong? This is from George Knight's
search for identity. Is he a qualified
Adventist source on SDA history?
Gentlemen, for those that do not know,
George Knight is an Adventist
historian, lauded light of the Adventist
movement. Notice what he says. Quote,
"One branch of the restorationist
movement had special importance to
Seventh Day Adventists, the Christian
Connection." James White and Joseph
Bates, two of Adventism's three
founders, were members of the Christian
Connection. Beyond that, Joshua Vheims,
the second most influential Millerite
leader, was also a connectionist
minister. All in all, the Christian
Connection made an extremely large
impact on both Millerite Adventism and
later Sabotarian
Adventism. Beyond general thinking
patterns, two examples will have to
suffice. The first is that Joseph Bates,
the apostle of the Sabbath, would frame
the seventh day Sabbath as as one of the
things needed to be restored to the
church before Christ could
return. A second is that Bates and James
White brought anti-trinitarianism into
Adventism from their restorationist
background. Certain restorationists
pointed out that the Bible nowhere uses
the word trinity. They eventually came
to regard the Trinity as one of those
doctrines Christianity adopted during
the Middle Ages as a product of the
great apostasy from scripture. Close
quote. Well, according to these guys,
Bates was right about the Sabbath, but
he and James were wrong about their back
to the Bible discoveries when it came to
the Trinity being a product of the great
apostasy that made the uh restoration of
the true church necessary in their
minds. But
why? Why are the anti-trinitarian and
anti-heavenly trio folks in your
movement wrong and you guys are right?
It's these same pioneers that they're
pointing to and agree with
you. They claim the pioneers just went
back to the Bible and rediscovered the
truth of the Sabbath and that the
trinity was a pagan corruption of truth
from the Middle Ages.
Heck, the pioneers were so adamant about
this that as George Knight notes, the
truth of this needed to be restored
before Jesus could
return. Now, Matthew tried downplaying
the fact that these guys were dogmatic
idoltors, preachers of a false god,
preaching curses and damnation on the
actual body of Christ, claiming they
worshiped a false god and the Adventists
were restoring the true church.
He tried painting it like they were just
these noble individuals that because
they were genuine, it excuses all of
this. Yeah. Not quite.
Um. Yes. And uh, of course, they were
aware of the creeds. And, uh, instead of
focusing so much on the creeds as the
human authority, they wanted to go back
to the word of God. And so that's what
they did. And in doing that, they they
uh stripped the Trinity of some things
and and and certainly went further than
we go today. Uh yeah.
Well, I find it's interesting to see
where they put their energy, you know,
cuz
Yeah. And Dr. Lake, look at what your
fellow colleague Jerry Mood admits in
his book about the heavenly trio.
Quote, "More recently, a further
question has arisen with increasing
urgency. Was the pioneers belief about
the godhead right or
wrong?" As one line of reasoning goes,
either the pioneers were wrong and the
present church is right, or the pioneers
were right and the present 7th Adventist
Church has apostatized from biblical
truth. Close quote. And this puts you
guys in quite the bind.
Which of you truly went back to the
Bible? Which group of you went back to
the Bible? You tell us that's all the
pioneers were doing. They just made
these discoveries based on going back to
the
Bible. George Knight tells us the same
thing. And that one of those discoveries
was that the Trinity was a pagan product
of the Middle Ages that crept in as a
part of the great apostasy from
scripture.
So that would mean that you guys today
aren't in line with the Bible because
you don't agree with them on this and
said they stripped away things that they
shouldn't
have. Or you're saying the pioneers
weren't in line with scripture. They
weren't actually just going back to the
Bible. And you guys today are allegedly
the correct representation of
that. Again, you guys are supposed to
have the great controversy
theme, the theological God particle, the
mind of God, the antidote to theological
division. You're not supposed to have
any doctrinal confusion. This is
supposed to give you guys the key to
unlock
everything, making you guys completely
distinct and separate from the rest of
us
Babylonians. Yet, at every
turn, it's theological confusion and
division.
Gee, almost as if Adventism is the exact
thing it projects onto everyone else.
We're talking about a restorationist
movement. You've got a group of people
who are coming out of a lot of other
faith traditions and have a certain
level of assumption between well, we all
agree that Jesus is our savior and we
believe in the Bible and we believe.
It's it's funny that the the fundamental
pillars that we really put our energy on
in those early years was things like
Sabbath and the sanctuary and state of
the stuff we really did differ on with
these other churches is where we put all
of our focus. The Trinity wasn't one of
those, right? And if we knew if we were
intentionally or knowingly changing our
doctrine of the Trinity, we would have
put a ton more energy towards that, I
would think. Yeah. Because otherwise we
if we weren't saying much different then
we were just going to keep moving on.
Yeah.
Right. The focus of the SDA pioneers was
the Sabbath esquetology including false
date setting. The state of the dead
stuff they really differed on with
Christians. Those are their pillars. Not
the
Trinity. Not whether or not you have a
false god. Nope. Not as important as
being on board with false date setting
leading to an entirely novel worldview
predicated upon a false understanding of
God, which was allegedly given by God
himself. Gentlemen, this has red flags
all over
it. That admission is enough to say,
"Yeah, hard pass on the Adventist
movement. I'm going to I'm going to move
along." when the defense is given that
sure, you know, the avenous pioneers
were christoologgical
heretics. But it's because that really
wasn't one of their
focuses. It was esquetology, date
setting, the state of the dead,
etc. Friend, looking back with hindsight
to say, had they known that the doctrine
of the trinity would change, they would
have put more effort into it. No, see,
this is the problem.
There shouldn't have ever been any need
for this. This was settled a long time
ago. The Christian church hasn't and
wasn't in universal apostasy for 1900
years worshiping a false god. This is
Christianity 101. Building block
catechetical level parts of theology
starting
points. I mean, five-year-olds at my
church are taught this stuff, folks.
This is around long before the Adventist
pioneers. The problem was not like,
well, they were sincere and they, you
know, no, they were a bunch of heretics
that up and deemed themselves because of
their own pride that they were some
special movement and some special move
of God, etc., when they had no business
being involved in any of
this. You shouldn't wish that they would
have foresaw the doctrine of the
movement changing. You should wish that
they would have repented and turned to
the true God before they perished under
his just condemnation.
And I think something that's really come
out in uh in subsequent generations of
scholars who have studied early
adventism in the trinity is that part of
their rejection for the trinity is is uh
you noted Michael is that they didn't
like the word. Okay. But also I think
they fundamentally misunderstood what
the trinity actually taught. I mean a
number of them did. Uh Joseph Bates for
instance at one time said if you can
convince me that that we are one in this
sense talking about him and his father
his earthly father being one that you
are my father and I your son and that I
am your father and you my son then I can
believe in the trinity you know so he's
looking at his own dad saying you know
we have this father-son relationship but
we're not like one one in this sense and
what he's referring to here is he's he's
really dealing with modalism that's what
he's that's what he's really trying to
to to push back against which he
associated with the trinity and I think
clearly in this case he didn't really
understand what the trinity was and I
think that that accounted for for his
rejection of it. Um you know he said in
one case uh respecting the trinity I
concluded that it was impossible for me
to believe that the lord Jesus Christ
the son of the father was also the
almighty god the father one in the same
being. It's like no the trinity isn't
saying they're one in the same being.
Like that's this is that's the point. So
it's it's really fascinating that we
have some of these statements where
they're rejecting the trinity and what
they're really rejecting is you know in
this case modalism or you know in
another case Lboro said if if father son
and holy ghost are each god it would be
three gods. He's trying to reject
polytheism or tritheism
right? That's what he's trying to get
rid of in rejecting the trinity. And I
think once we realized what the trinity
actually was, uh, you know, I I it was
natural for Adventism to to embrace it.
It's just there was these
misconceptions. I think early on they
were actually rejecting the things that
Trinity doctrine was established to
reject. Modalism, tritheism. I mean,
that's what they were trying to reject.
They just unfortunately associated it
with trinitarianism somehow.
No, they aren't one being. That's not
what they're saying. That's not what the
Trinity is saying. Did you catch
that? Matthew, I don't even think you
know what you're talking about. He just
said earlier, three persons, one being.
Now, here he's talking about Bates,
Joseph Bates, and his developing view.
And that, well, he wasn't actually
rejecting trinitarianism. He was
actually rejecting modalism. He just
didn't understand what the trinity was.
And he talks about the analogy of the
father and the son, etc., And if they're
the same being, yada yada. But then he
says, "No, it's not saying that they're
the same
being." Yeah, it
is.
Yeah. They're not the same person.
They're the same being.
But Matthew, this is why you guys should
have chosen to respond to our
presentation focused on the SDA pioneers
and their historical development of the
Trinity in Adventism because we read the
quotes that you're referring to and
countless
others. How is any of this actually
responding to the 22nd clip of me that
you guys
played? You guys haven't defined person.
Remember what my objections were in the
clip that they played?
The way they define things is errantly
defined. I then proceeded to in the
following hour and a half after that
explain my case using their own sources
to define
things. They're not engaging with
this. It doesn't even appear like you
guys know why I even brought up those
quotes either because I don't think you
guys have seen that presentation either.
I brought them up to say, "Don't you
think it's problematic that Bates
believed in a false
god?" He was a pioneer allegedly raised
up by God to help restore the true
church, but didn't actually believe in
the real
God. Worshiped an idol and thought he
knew better than the entirety of the
Christian church, and that their creeds,
which enshrine what the Bible teaches
about the true God, were an abomination.
This doesn't seem to concern you
gentlemen, which is extremely
unfortunate. But
furthermore, how is any of this again
addressing anything I've
said? I was told that I was only being
mentioned here
incidentally despite Dr. Campbell at the
beginning saying the focus was to listen
to me and hear if Adventism was
accurately represented. I wasn't talking
SDA history in the clip you played, but
even in the context in which I do, I've
shared all the information that you guys
have said so far. Literally none of this
stuff is
new. Jerry Moon's paper on historical
development, James White, Bates,
Loftboro, Ellen, Madison, and so on. We
looked at it all. That presentation was
four hours long.
It should greatly concern you that these
pioneers didn't understand what they
were even
rejecting and that tons of infighting
and division resulted because of this
even up to the present
day. Even after Ellen White's death
where you have people like EJ Wagner
teaching Jesus had a
beginning. I know he wasn't created but
he had a beginning. that's still popping
up post Ellen White's
death being taught to
people. It's like Christians hear
something like this, which is what that
presentation was for, and I don't think
Adventists understand how oddly it hits
their
ears. You're talking about the founders
of your movement having zero concept and
understanding of the true
God. But you want us to believe the true
God raised them up to restore apostolic
Christianity. What?
And the defense for the pioneers is well
they actually did embrace the trinity.
They just didn't know it or call it
that. They were just trying to reject
modalism, tritheism, etc. But they
fundamentally embraced the beliefs. Uh
yeah, except for that pesky great
controversy narrative that your
organization is stuck
with. And foundational to that is the
exaltation and giving of authority to
Jesus who was made equal with his
father.
The pioneers were teaching things like
Jesus had a
beginning. That's not just trying to
reject modalism. That's not using the
best vocabulary, you
know. It's not like, you know, they're
trying to put forth this this like they
are here that, well, they were just
trying to reject modalism and they just
didn't use the best vocabulary to do so.
No, that isn't a belief and explanation
that one states to try and say they're
rejecting tritheism. It's just outright
heresy.
How did I misrepresent Adventism? I
haven't misrepresented anything. I
explained what I meant by the words I
used in the small clip of me that you
guys played. And I did so with primary
source documentation. You guys played
that and now are rambling on about SDA
history that I'm not only aware of, but
I've shared with others. All these
quotes, all this stuff are not only in
that video, they're on our website.
All four of them are still just using
standard Christian terminology but not
defining when the center of my
objections are on precisely that. Even
in the small clip they played it was on
definitions. We haven't heard anything
about definitions except we heard Dr.
Campbell there talk about divine
persons and we saw in Jerry Moon's paper
how that's defined because it was
confirmed by Ellen in
vision having literal tangible
form and then Ellen confirms it by
talking to Jesus
himself. But unlike them, I'm utilizing
authority source documentation to
support my claims.
sources that they have to try and
retrofit with their modern modified view
to say what they believe and seek to
make it harmonious with their modern
position because Ellen White's early
beliefs are in line and supportive of
the early pioneers. She then develops
further and moves slightly away from
there with
caveats things like well the father
alone is the great lawgiver but both
father and son are.
You know, early on she was saying the
father alone is the great lawgiver. But
then that changed later. It's like, oh
well, they're both the great
lawgiver and things like, oh, you know,
the Holy Spirit's an actual person,
meaning has a literal tangible form.
But she did not start out having an
identical view to the four gentlemen on
screen, which is why what they want to
claim is out of harmony with many
statements. And they have to try and
redefine what's meant from their present
vantage point and act as though they're
consistent with that. The quotes that
those quotes from previous before their
current position
developed that those previous quotes are
actually in line with their current
vantage point. They have to try and
redefine everything and say, "Well, you
have to, you know, you don't you don't
really know what she's saying
there." They can dismiss James and Bates
and Loftboro, but they can't do that
with Ellen. They're stuck with
her. And gentlemen, I hate to be the
bearer of bad news, but present truth is
not going to get you out of this one.
Okay.
Yeah. And that's that's kind of an
interesting detail you say there. The
pioneers didn't always agree. It's true.
They didn't always they didn't always
speak about these topics like the
Trinity in the same way. You know, Bates
has his view in here, but he's he's
fighting modalism. How do you how do you
explain are early pioneers varying
viewpoints here and then put that
towards some sort of a consensus later
on? Because I know by, you know, the
1870s, um, Adventism is starting to
actually kind of narrow down the field.
certain people who had been
anti-trinitarian are shifting slightly.
Um even Ella White is making stronger
statements towards a more traditional
view here. Uh what what starts to happen
in at least that early to late pioneer
time frame the that made us start to
kind of agree on some things. I think
what you mentioned there, Greg, is is
key. It's the trajectory, you know,
where what where all of this was heading
and and where it is today. And that's
that's what people outside of Adventism
as well as within need to to do is look
at the big picture and to see where
we've ended up today. Um the trajectory
that's gotten us here and and you just
hit the uh you know the nail on the head
with with the evolving understanding uh
throughout the 19th century. And of
course Ellen White played a key role um
even in in those early years. You can
see she was on a a different trajectory
in terms of the trinity than her
colleagues, but she was always careful
in her wording with that. And uh she
became more pronounced, more specific uh
as as the years went on, especially when
you get into the latter part of the the
19th century. And I think we all know
that the the desire of ages that was
like the turning point. Um yeah, 1898
when that was published. Uh and uh that
that classic statement
um that
uh I got it here somewhere un un Yeah.
Well, in Christ was life original. Yeah.
Unbared, underived. And that and then at
the same book she said that the Holy
Spirit was the third person of the
Godhead. And uh that that was the
turning point. And you see a a a
significant change after that, a new
trajectory on the Trinity that has has
continued to evolve even up into to
recent years. And what I think is
important with regard to what we saw
with answering Adventism about that what
is called a false trinity that is not
the Adventist trinity. And and if you
follow Adventist theologians even uh in
in the latter part of the n 20th century
I think of Raul Deteran probably the
most influential theologian in Adventist
theologian in the 20th century and in
1970 he published a extremely important
seinal uh article in Andrews University
seminary studies called the do a
reflection on the doctrine of the
trinity and in that article and I've
heard it seen that's cited so often in
the years since then. Uh he is so clear
on the oneness of
God and the
the three persons of the Godhead. In
fact, I have a on a screen over here,
one of my screens. Let me read to you a
statement on pageuh 16 of that. And I'm
going to turn away here. Forgive me just
a moment, but I've got it over here.
I've got a bunch of stuff on these
screens. But he says, "Therefore, we
must confess," this is page 16 of of
this this important article. Therefore,
we must confess that the Trinity is one
indivisible God and that the
distinctions of the persons do not
destroy the divine unity. This unity of
God is expressed by saying that he is
one substance. Nevertheless, in the
divine unity, there are three co-eternal
and co-equal persons who through though
distinct are the one undivided and
adorable God. This is the doctrine of
scripture and that
is the teaching of seventh day
adventism this day to this day I should
add it's its theological nerve center if
you listen to contemporary Adventist
theologians and those sense deterrenine
uh this the idea that God is
one in his essence in his substance but
three persons that is standard that is
quite standard so that depiction we saw
at the beginning is categorically false
and and a far cry from what reality is
and and mainstream Adventist theological
thinking on the triune God.
Oh, far cry from Adventist theology in
the mainstream. He says, and the chart
that I showed is is misrepresenting, he
says. No, this isn't a
misrepresentation. We will get to Dr.
Derin in a
moment. As we saw earlier, she said,
because that's what this was being based
off of. Because remember folks, what
does he talk about in that paper? That
Ellen White's view, these guys tried to
say where was the trajectory? Where was
it going? Yeah, Jerry Moon already told
us away from orthodox credle
trinitarianism, but also away from where
the pioneers
were. Gee, almost like I uh was saying
that it's a unique
concept. She said the sun is the eternal
self-existent one. This was in 1900,
gentlemen, after the desire of ages when
all this stuff was supposed to be ironed
out. She said that the heavenly trio's
three beings, that Jesus was the only
being that could be led into the
councils of God the Father, which
implies the Father is a distinct being.
And by person, you guys mean having a
literal tangible
form. But Dr. Lake says she chose her
words very carefully. Yet none of this
comports with orthodoxy.
The visual is to try and show the
difference visually between what
Christians are saying and what
Adventists or Adventism proper is
saying. You guys are not saying what
Christians are as depicted in this
image. This is a fact. You aren't
because you consistently
can't. It does not comport with the
great controversy
narrative. And I'd love to actually
discuss this with you face to face, Dr.
lake and see who is and isn't
misrepresenting. This is why this notion
that all you guys did here was engaged
in SDA history is misleading because no,
you weren't. You're making claims about
my cred credibility. But the appeal to
to Raul Dedan, the poster child of of
SDA scholars that they'll point to and
say exactly what Lake did. He proves
Adventist theology proper is orthodox on
Christology and the Trinity. We will
circle back around to this after we work
through some of his other claims which
demonstrate why this appeal does not
save them. For
starters, this isn't a subject that one
needs to be getting more specific on in
the 19th century. Dr.
Lake, and that's why I'm not really sure
that you guys understand or hear the
real
issues. Gentlemen, I have said all of
the stuff you are saying from this
platform.
Nothing you're saying is actually
addressing any of the objections I've
made or shown that I've misrepresented
Adventism. You played a one minute clip,
20 seconds or so of it. Saying you were
listening to hear if Adventism was
misrepresented and all of this was
leading to the claim that one has to see
where the trajectory and development was
going and that Ellen wasn't in line with
her
cohorts. Now, what did we look at
earlier?
Jerry Moon recognizes the two flavors of
the heavenly trio theology in her
writings. That's what you mean by Ellen
White was going somewhere. Yeah, she was
confused and had zero business claiming
to receive thousands of revelations from
the one true God that she clearly did
not know or
understand. In the clip you played, I
went on to support my claims and define
them clearly showing why I was making
the claims I did. And Adventist history
has nothing to do with the point that
was being made
there because functionally you guys are
not trinitarians. Key word
functionally. It isn't enough to just
say the word when you fundamentally mean
something
different with regards to Dr. Lakes
defense that the point they're getting
at is the trajectory of where they are
today, which was basically to say,
"Yeah, we we know the Pioneers were off,
but Ellen White was led by God early on
and course corrected, and now they have
it correct, even though early on they
weren't." Dr. Lake, one would only give
this apologetic if they didn't
understand the core problem with
this. It didn't need clarified in the
19th century.
We didn't need somebody to come along
and formulate some concept that was
going
somewhere. This is ancient theology,
sir. They shouldn't have had any
confusion on this matter. It's been
clear and clarified for roughly 1500
years before your pioneers even
existed. He said the desire of ages was
the turning point. Like I said earlier,
and we saw in Jerry Moon's paper. Yeah,
Dr. Like we know this because in the
video you're reacting to we looked at
that same quote that we looked at
earlier and it doesn't help you because
the Jesus in the desire of ages is not
the real real Christ. It is a
counterfeit a counterfeit a pseudo
Christoy. Notice from Moon's paper quote
finally in 1897 Ellen White wrote that
the Holy Spirit is the third person of
the Godhead. This affirmation received
wider circulation and more permanent
form in the desire of ages
1898. At the same time, her belief in
the absolute and eternal equality of
Christ with the father was made uh un
unequivocally emphatic. In Christ is
life, she wrote original, unbared,
underived. There's the quote they were
mentioning. With this clear articulation
of the unity of God and a plurality of
eternal divine persons, her
trinitarianism is essentially complete.
All that remains for her capstone
statement is to affirm explicitly that
the three eternal heavenly dignitaries,
the three living persons of the heavenly
trio are one in nature, character, and
purpose, but not in person. Thus, there
is a clear progression from the simple
to the complex, showing that Ellen
White's understanding did grow in chains
and change as she received additional
light. Close quote. Right? Not from
Bible study. Let that be clear
again. This development was not coming
from Bible study. It came from visions
which Moon admits in the conclusion of
the paper is one of the key influences
in this development that Dr. Lake is
trying to put forth as a defense. It
developed based on
visions. Furthermore, Moon doesn't get
into definitions here. He appeals to the
same thing Dr. Lake does that. She said
Christ is eternally equal with the
father which again to the SDA pioneers
meant Jesus came into being. He wasn't
created. He had a
beginning but it was his coming forth
and having a beginning was so far back
in the in the past that to us it's
essentially
eternal. He says Ellen White's capstone
statement says the heavenly trio is one
in nature, character, and purpose. And
we just saw how by nature that includes
having a physical tangible
body and then apparently also an angelic
nature like we also
saw. But even if we put all that
aside, all of it, Ellen White's capstone
statement doesn't save you all, Dr.
like because she claimed all the
statements came from God, including the
earlier ones like we saw in Spirit of
Prophecy Volume 1. And your organization
still upholds these statements as direct
revelation from God himself. And Ellen
White claims she never wrote a single
sentence of
heresy. One straight chain of
truth. That is, sir, unless you're
willing to go on record and say she was
wrong, which I highly, highly doubt
since you enjoy your
job. But the movement's early stage
Christology is necessary for your great
controversy narrative and worldview,
gentlemen. That's why I'm constantly
hammering
this because it is the theological
elephant in the room that has you all in
a catch22. Either Ellen didn't receive
the early statements from God, which
means she's a false prophet, or she did,
and the latter statements contradict the
previous ones. But either way, it
doesn't work, and God didn't reveal this
stuff to
her. It's like when Adventist
scholarship tries to act like all of
Ellen's blunders are par for the course.
No different than the biblical writers,
etc., All they evidence is the weakness
of the avenous gods because the true god
isn't the world's worst communicator.
She wasn't a historian. That's the
newest defense of her historical
blunders. It's like once again ignoring
the elephant in the room that she was
allegedly getting a direct download from
God
himself. She claimed the words in great
controversy patriarchs and prophets and
desire of ages are barricaded by a thus
sayeth the
Lord. It's like the messages book three
page
122. and great
controversy is chocked full of alleged
history. But on top of all of that, Dr.
Lake, this 1898 being the turning point
claim isn't even entirely accurate.
Folks, notice the
transcript from the 1980, not
1880, 1980 General Conference in
session, which is documented for us in
the April 23rd, 1980 issue of the
Adventist Review.
This is some of the delegates going back
and forth over how the word uh how to
word their fundamental belief on the
scriptures. Within that discussion,
current the the current GC president uh
Ted Wilson, his dad Neil Wilson, who was
the then GC president, he asked the
question, who has some help for us on
this or some question with regard to the
godhead or
trinity wherein they go on to discuss
the
belief. Leif Hansen says, quote, "In
this discussion of the Trinity, which is
always a difficult matter to discuss, I
wonder if a certain misunderstanding
could be eliminated eliminated by saying
a unity in purpose so that the matter of
physical unity may be
eliminated." Neil Wilson then says, "I
see your point there. Maybe we ought to
make it a unity and purpose rather than
a physical unity."
Bennett then says, "The statement about
the Godhead and the Trinity goes on to
use the pronoun he later as the Father,
Son, and the Holy Ghost are discussed.
We use the same pronoun he. I do
recognize and accept the Trinity as a
collective unity, but I would have
little difficulty in applying the
pronoun he to the Trinity or the
Godhead. For me, this has deep
theological
implications." Dr. Lake and gentlemen at
the Adventist History podcast. Your guys
leaders are still trying to figure this
stuff out in
1980. It's like almost a hundred years
after Desire of Ages supposedly settled
things. You still have people in your
movement at this point that are trying
to figure out how your movement wants to
word things on a subject that's been
understood by Christians for 2,000
years.
If this movement would humble itself and
just accept this and embrace orthodoxy,
you wouldn't have these issues. But a
movement built on pride begets more of
the same
thing. But for those in the audience, go
and read this transcript for yourself,
folks, and see the division and
confusion for yourselves and how Ellen
White and her wording is appealed to as
the language that needs to be embraced
for the wording of their belief. And
with hindsight, we can see that's what
happened. And Jerry Moon recognizes such
in his
paper. That's what Ellen White's
visions that guided them. It was Ellen
White's visions that ultimately guided
them because they seek to use language
in accordance with her and her language
came from supposed visions, not Bible
study. Do not fall for the bait when an
Adventist claims all of Adventist
beliefs are based strictly on the Bible.
No, they're not.
I know Adventists out there may
genuinely believe that and I'm not
dismissing that. I too believe that same
thing when I was an Adventist and I used
to tout it to all sorts of
people. I'd get asked constantly,
"What's the Seventh Day Adventist?" "Oh,
we just believe the Bible." It was
always my go hammered in my head.
Hammered in my head because I believed I
could point to a proof text somewhere.
And just because I could point to a
proof text, I was justified because if I
can. But then I actually learned the
facts and I changed my belief because
Jesus Christ is the truth and truth
aligns with
facts, not affinity or allegiance to an
organization. But furthermore, let's
look at some stuff from Desire of Ages
and test this theory further. They want
us to believe that Adventists believe in
the same God as Christians and Desire of
Ages onward proves it.
Notice verse what Moon
says. Quote, "She clearly rejected any
view of the Trinity that makes God
impersonal and unreal, but embraced a
literal biblical view of one God and
three persons who are relationally
united in character, purpose, and love."
These affirmations of belief in one God
and three persons were sufficiently
influential that by 1913 during her
lifetime was published the first
explicitly trinitarian belief statement
among 7th Day
Adventists. So for
starters this is what Moon recognizes as
Ellen White's post desire of ages view
of what they call the trinity. a literal
biblical view which means three physical
tangible forms that are relationally
united in character, purpose and love.
It doesn't matter if they use the word
persons or say divine persons because
what they mean is the real
issue. And remember what we saw earlier.
I want to read this again. Quote, in
1890, in the 1890s, when she became
convinced of the individuality and
personhood of the Holy Spirit, she
referred to the Holy Spirit in literal
and tangible terms, much like those she
had used in 1850 to describe the Father
and the Son. For instance, addressing
the church at Aenddale College in 1899,
she declared, "The Holy Spirit, who is
as much a person as God is a person, is
walking through these grounds unseen by
human eyes. He hears every word we utter
and knows every thought of the
mind." Yeah. Not trinitarian.
Trinitarians do not believe that God has
a
body or that there are three of those
that look like our form. Because Ellen
said in the great controversy to be made
in God's image isn't just in character
but also in form and
feature. It's like so do the Adventist
gods have reproductive
organs? I mean she claimed man being
made in God's image means in physical
features as
well. And again great controversy
supposed to be barricaded by a thus
sayeth the Lord. Quote in the beginning
man was created in the likeness of God
not only in character but in form and
feature.
So based on all of what we've seen so
far, they claim father, son, and spirit
all possess the same nature. They all
possess physical literal forms. And
these forms look like human forms
because we are made in the image of God.
And there's three of
those. Now, don't tell me the chart that
I showed is not consistent with with
what's being put forth here.
Your own personal anecdotes and your own
personal opinion are not what that video
was
about. But there's three of those there.
There's three physical tangible forms.
And she couldn't behold the fathers cuz
he was too glorious. Jesus isn't though.
She could behold Jesus. And the Holy
Spirit, he has a physical tangible form.
when he was walking around in Australia
in the 1890s, but he's
invisible physical body like us, but is
invisible. Except, well, not really, cuz
she said the Holy Spirit
was divested of personality and is
Christ's representative in his absence
because incarnate he couldn't be
omnipresent. And that's in the desire of
ages. These statements are one year
apart from one another.
And the Adventist Jesus apparently has a
divine nature, an angelic nature, and a
human nature, but they all share in the
same nature.
It just
like when the SDA pioneers argued God
having a physical body by nature, they
thought to deny this and claim God is
not contained to a physical body meant
that you weren't that you were advocate
advocating for
pantheism, which is just ridiculous. But
Moon talks about this in his paper, too.
Notice talking about Ellen White here.
In a follow-up letter, she zeroed in on
the core issue. This is talking about
her. He's talking about here her her
back and forth with John Harvey Kellogg.
The Lord Jesus did not represent God as
an essence pervading nature, but as a
personal being. Christians should bear
in mind that God has a personality as
verily as has Christ.
Kellogg countered by arguing that if the
Holy Spirit could be everywhere at once,
as even the anti-trinitarians believed,
and if the Holy Spirit were also a
person, as Ellen White had asserted in
Desire of Ages, then God could be
allervasive without being impersonal. He
tried to convince church leaders that
the pantheism of living temple was
simply a scientific version of the same
doctrine of God that Ellen White had
expressed in Desire of Ages.
Ellen White, however, insisted that
Kellogg's concept of the Trinity was not
the same as her concept, and as the
conflict dragged on into 1905. She
exposed the matter to the church in such
stark lines that she could not be
misunderstood. the most scathing
indictment she ever wrote against a
false view of the Trinity. This
manuscript labels Kellogg's view as
spiritualistic, nothingness, imperfect,
untrue, the trail of the serpent and the
depths of Satan. Close
quote. So, John Harvey Kellogg wasn't a
pantheist, by the way, folks. He was
more akin to a
panentheist. Pantheism versus pentheism.
two different things. But when arguing
with him about the nature of God, Ellen
White argued that because Jesus
represented God to the world in the
incarnation and he was personal, meaning
he has a physical tangible form, that
has to mean the Father and the Holy
Spirit do too because God has a
personality as verily as Jesus is. Are
you seeing
this? Don't tell me I'm making things up
and misrepresenting things, Dr. Lake.
And how ironic the most scathing rebuke
she ever wrote was against a false view
of the trinity when she herself had a
false god. But it is this sort of meu
that their their claims about the ning
creed arose out of the creed gets
saddled as being like Kellogg's
impersonal
view when it says God is without body or
parts. It spiritualizes God away and
makes him impersonal and unreal because
it removes the physical tangible form
from God which we saw in the previous
quote from page 146 of Moon's paper
which Ellen White rejected which would
mean she had to reject her own
conception of the Holy Spirit in Desire
of Ages because she said the Holy Spirit
is divested of personality of humanity.
So I guess the Holy Spirit was unreal
and imaginary.
Nevertheless, while Kellok's theology
was wrong, he wasn't wrong in that
regard. That God does not possess a body
by nature, and that isn't what makes God
a personal being. God is a personal
being by virtue of possessing the
ability to speak, be spoken to,
etc. What makes God God isn't a set of
eyes and ears and a mouth, etc.
Like I said earlier, if you piece apart
a human body, you no longer have a human
body because a human body is a composite
creation made up of various parts. God
is not like this. He's not made up of
made up of parts such that he could be
taken apart and then no longer
exist. And let me just also say,
gentlemen, I don't buy this excuse from
SDA critics of
Christianity that everyone learns and
grows, etc. because the facts are the
information was readily available in the
days of these
pioneers. It has been common Christian
catechetical knowledge for nearly 2,000
years. These guys will go on, and we'll
see this in part two, where they try and
defend the pioneers heresy by saying,
"Well, they were basically ignores, so
cut them some
slack." They were allegedly arguing
against things they didn't actually
understand correctly, something Matthew
said
earlier. And in Ellen White's case, she
was allegedly uh, you
know, getting this directly from God
himself. Yeah. Totally ludicrous. This
is such a horrible defense in the
context of trinitarian theology. They
should have made sure they actually
understood what they were anathematizing
and preaching damnation against, calling
pagan, etc. I mean, they weren't even
bright enough to learn basic Christian
terminology, such as what the creed
means when it says God is without body
and parts.
And I also don't buy the excuse that not
all Christians today necessarily
understand that
language. You're comparing a modern lay
Christian with a group that claim to be
pioneering God's last day remnant church
with the fullness of the truth and
preaching damnation on everyone else but
their small little sect. Yeah, not a
fair comparison. It's like if you're
going to do something that radical, you
better understand what you're talking
about. and every pew sitting, you know,
Christian isn't making such a radical
claim and going out of their way to do
what the pioneers
did. Now, with regards to God being
a simple being, not a complex or
composite being, this is why divine
simplicity is another vital doctrine in
this
discussion. Something that, of course,
you guessed it, the SDA church rejects.
First, let's listen to a small clip from
Dr. Sinclair Ferguson who explains
divine simplicity and its significance
with regards to trinitarian theology.
Then we're going to read a statement
from a paper put out by the Adventist
Biblical Research
Institute.
Standby. What do we mean when we speak
about the simplicity of God? This
doctrine that has been held and
expounded by almost all the great
theologians of the Christian church from
Irenaeus in the early centuries through
Augustine and Anelm and Thomas Aquinas
and the great Puritans and the great
Orthodox reformed theologians. What do
we mean by the simplicity of God?
We mean something so stunning, so
singular as to say that God, as the
Westminster Confession of Faith puts it,
that God
is pure
spirit, that he is without
body
parts or
passions. Or to put it in other terms
echoing what we have already heard today
that God is without origin that God is
without
composition that God is without
becoming. He
is and in a sense that is the first and
the last word that is to be said about
God. He is as God and he is all he is
always that he
is. As the older theologians used to
say, there is no potential in God. God
is all that he
is. And of course the beauty of that is
that God reveals himself in such simple
fullness to us in the wonderful mystery
but the beautiful
interconnectedness of his tripal being
so that we might say it is never boring
for God always to be all that he
is. And that as God enjoys his own being
in a personal way, it is not as though
we speak like the philosophers of a
merely monadic
monocromic unmoved first mover, but of
our glorious tripersonal God who in
Father and Son and Holy Spirit as it
were interpenetrate one another's joys
in one
another and share together all that it
means for God to be all that he is all
of the time.
So when Ferguson uh when he says that
God is all that he is always that he is
he simply means that God is love just
merciful omnipotent etc and always has
been what he is
eternally like I said earlier that's
also what not having passions is in
reference to God is not like a fallen
man who waivers or loses faith and
fluctuates and falters etc. He's
eternally
consistent. But this movement doesn't
understand that because they inherited I
know they talk about well our pioneers
have moved along and you know we've
grown since the pioneers etc. Yeah. Not
in this area you haven't. And they I
still hear them utilize this false
understanding of well the creed says
that God doesn't have passions which
means he's not actually relatable. He
doesn't have any
emotions. No. That's what these silly
pioneers didn't understand.
that Adventists unfortunately in the
modern day have inherited. But now
notice from God in three persons in
theology which was put out in uh 2015 by
the Adventist
Barri. Quote, "The notion of divine
simplicity meant among other things
indivisibility and
undifferentiation." It meant
what? Indivisibility and undifferiation.
The challenge the Orthodox party faced
was to show how Jesus and the Holy
Spirit could be divine entities and
still maintain divine simplicity. The
Nyine Constantinople creeds apparent
solution was to predicate one essence of
God ensuring that it is intellectual in
nature.
John Zazulus who is a Greek Orthodox
bishop reading of history would suggest
that the Capidosians advance this
thought a little bit further away from
the materialistic connotation in the
idea of divine essence by recasting Usia
in personal
terms. He takes the view that St. Basil
primarily and St. Gregory of Nazanzis
and St. Gregory of Nissa that's a
misspelling on this guy's part with him
took the classical language of Greek
ontology Usia hypostasis etc and
redefined it in personal and relational
terms. The basic nature of reality was
no longer substance but relationship on
account of this traditional
understanding of the oneness of God in
the trinitarian
formulation. It seems clear that when
Adventists affirm that God is one, they
mean something different than what the
tradition
[Music]
affirms. Without a burden to define r uh
rationally God's oneness, Adventists are
uncomfortable with interpreting or
defining it with reference to substance
in such terms as simplicity,
undifferentiation,
etc. close quote. Yeah, Dr. Like I
didn't misrepresent anything in the
video of me that you were clipping. My
thesis was clear. Show Christians that
what Adventists mean by trinity isn't
what Christians
mean. We have yet another scholar in
this movement who was an associate
director at the
BARRI. one of the highest body of
theological gathering in the Adventist
church who tells us what Adventists mean
when they talk about the subject is
different than what Christian the
Christian church
means. So why do you guys keep publicly
trying to act like you do
gentlemen? Stop trying to postulate that
people like myself are misrepresenting.
This has nothing to do with
understanding there was historical
development within Adventism. We know
for crying out loud. We
know. And what it developed into isn't
trinitarianism. That's the entire
point. And I get so bent out of shape
about this because it's
dishonest. And then you project that
onto people like myself that we're the
ones that are misrepresenting and we're
dishonest. No, I'm
not. No, I'm not.
And I'm going to respond when you guys
claim such. Don't tell me I'm being
dishonest. I could go on and on and on
with more and more sources. That's why I
think you guys actually don't want to
have face tof face discussions because
you know these receipts are going to get
pulled out and you're going have to find
a way to defend
them. What we just read there, this is
what I was saying. We'd circle back to
Raul
Ded confused mess. We just read or we
just heard Dr. Lake
earlier say that well Rald Dedan he's
this big poster child of of of Adventist
Christologology that it's orthodox one
essence. Yeah. And then we have a
scholar here that's like well
technically we uh we reject divine
simplicity on terms that it eliminates
the the relatableness and personality of
God because again they define person
differently than Christians
do. And just like Ellen White was going
back and forth with Kellogg, if he
doesn't have a physical body, then it
makes him unreal and
imaginary. Just use your own term. The
heavenly trio trinity is taken. Sorry
fellas, it's off limits. Sorry. Find a
different term. That's the point. And
then start defending that. Then we can
have discussions around you defending
your God up and against the true God
like Elisha did with the false prophets
at
Baal or with
Baal. And then we can go to scripture
and see whose god can actually be
supported from
scripture. But again, they're not going
to use the term heavenly trio. They're
going to keep using the term trinity
because I suspect if they did use
heavenly trio that wouldn't resonate
with who the organization is trying to
target and
proilitize, which is Christians.
Christians would hear that term and go,
"Huh? The
what? The what?" And the SDA
organization doesn't want that. So, they
keep up this act of borrowing language,
but under the surface means something
entirely different to try and appear
like just another Christian group. And
I'm sure some of these people, probably
some of these gentlemen, they're
probably
genuine. You're going to you're going to
see in the later parts, they go on to
bo, you know, b and scoff and laugh
amongst themselves like
conspiracy. Yeah, I'm not the one that
brought up conspiracies, which is rather
rich coming from Seventh Day
Adventist. Like, you guys are the last
ones that should be laughingly joking
around about
conspiracy. Yeah, I never claimed it was
a
conspiracy. My claim is that you guys
are deceived, oftentimes well-meaning
people. And what you think you're
saying, you think is the same as
Christians. And I keep telling you it
isn't. I'm not going to be budged on
this until you're ready to
denounce the Barri, Ellen White, the
Pioneers, Ministry Magazine, Signs of
the Times, and all these other sort the
website. I'm going to keep making these
claims because it's true. just own it.
You guys are saying something
different. The SDA organization rejects
divine simplicity as extra biblical
philosophically imposed you know ideas
onto the text that you know not
realizing the giants of the faith that
Dr. Ferguson mentioned Irenaeus, Sirill,
Augustine, Thomas Aquinus, they all
utilize scripture to argue this against
actual pagans and their extra biblical
philosophies. And if you read this
paper, God in three
persons, you'll see how the picture is
painted that the Nying creed isn't
predicated on the Bible, but on
philosophy that dehumanizes God. Because
in their model, God is like a man. They
literally look like us and have bodies
by
nature. So, because the early church
didn't humanize God, that meant they
weren't really starting with
scripture. Yeah, sure. Some of them
tried using language at times that they
thought would reach a certain
demographic of
people, but Adventists in the modern day
do this exact same thing. Heck, that's
literally what these guys are
doing. You know, they'll point to some
of these individuals and be like, "Look,
they're using Greek philosophy." Yeah.
Because they're trying to reach and
evangelize
pagans. What they're fundamentally
saying is what the Bible teaches
though. It's not just they they paint
the picture like it's just Greek
philosophy and Aristotilian. And then
it's like you go and read these people.
I'm reading St. Gregory of
Nisses on the he was one of the
Capidosian fathers. So Eastern church
which poses a whole set of problems for
this movement by the
way. You know this is one of the few
places I've seen where you have an
Adventist scholar that's even
recognizing the Eastern Church. Not
saying they don't know it's around but
it poses serious problems for a lot of
their historical claims. There's sort of
conspiracies around the Western church
and Roman Catholicism. It's like, dude,
you have to take up all of this stuff as
well with the Assyrian church of the
East, the Marionite churches, the
Orthodox churches, Greek. It's like
these claims just fall so
flat. But I'm reading St. Gregory of
Nissas on the on the soul and
resurrection right now. And in the book,
he's literally arguing against actual
paganism. Actual paganism. And yet,
you'll get people like this. He's, and
by actual paganism, I mean he's arguing
against actual Greek philosophy,
philosophical
paganism. He's arguing against all of
that. And yet, he's somebody that this
organization will label as he believed
Greek
philosophy. No. Sometimes these
individuals used language like that
because believe it or not, they actually
wanted to try and reach the people they
were talking to and they were
essentially doing what Paul did,
becoming all things to all people type
thing. And not all of them did this. It
depends who we're talking about. But the
point being, this is further evidence
the SDA church means something entirely
different by the term
trinity. Their gods are time bound. We
haven't even gotten into
that. with that are individual beings
with bodies made up of
parts and they'll point to places in
scripture like the pioneers did like
Daniel 7 to claim that it's referring to
God the father having a body a physical
body by nature because the ancient of
days was sitting on the
throne and when Daniel saw in vision the
son of man approaching the ancient of
days that proves God the father has a
physical body by nature that's like ours
And as Jerry Moon pointed out earlier,
this was allegedly confirmed by God
himself who gave a vision to Ellen White
where she asked Jesus himself and he
told her
so. Except no, Daniel 7 is a vision and
God can manifest in his creation however
he sees fit. That doesn't mean he has a
physical body by nature.
Jesus is unique in that in the
incarnation and now this gets into the
economics versus the
uh essentially the ontology versus the
economics of the trinity. The economics
being where yeah there is unique
differences about them that's not like
the others like Jesus is the one that
incarnated not the father or the
spirit but that doesn't mean that
ontologically they're not equal. It just
means they're taking different roles in
redemption. So Jesus is unique in that
in the incarnation he added unto himself
a human nature that he will uh forever
retain as the God
man. But then continuing with desire of
ages. Then we have this dastardly
statement. I bring this up all the
time and Adventist don't don't bring up
Jesus saying, "My God, my God, why have
you forsaken me?" He's citing from the
Psalms. He's not saying what's what's
being said in this
quote. Quote, "Satan with his fierce
temptations rung the heart of Jesus. The
Savior could not see through the portals
of the tomb." Hope did not present to
him as coming forth from the grave of
conqueror or tell him of the father's
acceptance of the sacrifice. He feared
that sin was so offensive to God that
their separation was to be
eternal. Close quote. Yeah.
No, there's no possibility of
separation. But that's what they teach
in this model because that's what Ellen
White taught is that Jesus came and all
of heaven held out its breath as the sun
was here and he could have potentially
fallen and if he would have it would
have sent the whole cosmos into
chaos. Yet no, that goes against the
communication of the attributes. It goes
against the hypothetic union things that
the SDA church like we said or like I
said earlier and showed earlier tries to
claim they
affirm but it's only lip
service. But based on this quote the
Adventist Jesus didn't have unwavering
faith. He doubted because Satan was able
to twist his heart while he was on the
cross which caused him to be unsure if
his sacrifice would be accepted or if he
would be resurrected. And doubt is
unbelief and unbelief is a
sin. And this doesn't even get into the
problem
of Jesus incarnate has two
wills. What is called
diaphism because if he didn't truly have
a will as a man in his human nature,
then he wasn't truly human. Because part
of being truly human means that you have
a will.
But Jesus also shares in the singular
divine will as he's 100%
divine. So God has one single will,
father, son, and spirit have one single
will. Jesus also has a human will that
his human nature
possesses. So according to this
quote in his human nature, now remember
they they're saying he was only a man on
earth. But even if we wanted to grant to
them, okay, well, they affirm the
hypothetic union. This statement in
conjunction with that means that there
was division in the minds in the sorry
in the the will of the father or or
rather the the the son in his divine
nature and his human
nature like was he wavering as
God? Well, no. No, it's as a man. Okay.
So he was divided. Then it just there's
so many blunders with all this nonsense.
That's why we don't need all this extra
biblical
nonsense that
just this does not comport with
trinitarian theology at all. It comports
with the Adventist system which they
label trinitarian. But remember a
trinitarian
concept. Like he reiterates in the
conclusion of his paper. Since Ellen
White clearly held the basic formula of
one God and three persons, it can hardly
be denied that her view is essentially
trinitarian. However, her view differs
from traditional trinitarianism in the
following important
respects. He then goes on to give a
laundry list of reasons why they aren't
Orthodox
Trinitarians, which again, not trying to
be a one- string
banjo, but that was my entire thesis of
the video that these gentlemen clipped.
It's like what's so ironic about this is
Moon says her developing view is
essentially trinitarian. Yeah. The root
of the word essential is essence. And
that's exactly what we're talking about
when we talk about the being of God. Yet
they don't want to get specific on the
essence of God and what makes him
essentially one only how they relate
relationally. But here he has no problem
saying Ellen essentially came to accept
the Trinity.
So this is from the October 28, 1890
issue of the review and Herald. The same
decade Ellen White's visions corrected
error of the hol on the Holy Spirit all
of a sudden being a person. Now from
under the heading that asks is the Holy
Spirit a
person?
Quote, "Are we to understand that the
Holy Ghost is a person the same as the
Father and the Son? Some claim that it
is, other that it's not, others that
it's not. Answer the terms Holy Ghost
are a harsh and repulsive
translation. It should be Holy Spirit.
Hagon Numa in every instance. This
spirit is the spirit of God and the
spirit of Christ. The spirit being the
same whether it is spoken of as
pertaining to God or Christ. But
respecting this spirit, the Bible uses
expressions which cannot be harmonized
with the idea that it is a person like
the father and the son.
Rather, it is shown to be a divine
influence from them both. The medium
which represents their presence and by
which they have knowledge and power
through all the universe when not
personally
present. Close quote. Well, what did we
see earlier from Desire of Ages?
The Holy Spirit is Christ's
representative, but divested of the
personality of humanity and independent
thereof. Cumbered with humanity, Christ
could not be in every place personally.
Therefore, it was for their interest
that he should go to the father and send
the spirit to be his successor on earth.
No one could then have any advantage
because of his location or his personal
contact with Christ. By the spirit, the
Savior would be accessible to all. in
this sense he would be nearer to them
than if he had not ascended on
high. Close
quote. So the Adventist Jesus that's
supposed to be the same Jesus that the
Christian church worships isn't
omnipresent as a man because cumbered
with humanity he couldn't
be. And this is in line with their
kinosis interpretation of Philippians 2
which says Jesus was only a man on earth
and he set his divine nature aside. So
the Holy Spirit is Christ representative
but divevested of personality of
humanity and independent thereof. So
much for the Holy Spirit having a
physical body walking around invisibly
at Aenddale College in the 1890s. Both
claims cannot be true. Yet both
allegedly came from God
himself. We could go on and on and on
which I have before. The SDA church is
not trinitarian.
You don't get to come along in the 19th
century and take a term, redefine it,
and then insist that you agree with
those who do actually affirm what the
term
means. This why the doctrine of the
trinity was hammered out was for
specificity. Appealing to Raul Dedin
doesn't help you guys, Dr. Lake, because
the plethora of statements that we
looked at, and there's a mountain of
others, do not comport with orthodox
Christologology.
So appealing to someone like him who
Adventists love to point to to claim
that he proves Adventists are orthodox
only highlights the glaring
contradictions. And at the end of the
day, Dr. Dedim was still beholden to the
great controversy
worldview. The man had to have cognitive
dissonance going on. I just interviewed
Heraldo Kamacho a few weeks ago and it
premiered on the on the channel. He was
a student of Dr. deterren and he pointed
out the same thing. He said it
flabbergasted me how somebody who was
sound on christologology could then
still believe and and pedal the great
controversy
lie which is the exact
problem. I've never claimed there's not
a single Adventist out there anywhere
that believes orthodox Christologology.
I've never said
that. And Dr. Deteran either internally
had to accept that it was wrong, the
great controversy worldview, and he knew
the truth but wanted to make the peace
and not lose his livelihood or he didn't
actually understand and believe orthodox
Christology. Period. There is no in
between. Nothing I said in that clip was
disproven. And anyone that goes and
watches the whole thing will see me
demonstrate my claims with more than
just assertions, which is all these
gentlemen did here was make a bunch of
assertions.
Ellen White has more authority than Raul
Dedan or any other Adventist theologian,
living or
deceased. And all appealing to Dr. Dan
does is show the doctrinal
contradictions that have to be upheld in
order to keep your system in order to
try and uh you know play both sides of
the
fence. You guys want to be taken as
Orthodox Trinitarians who worship the
same God as Christians do. But at the
same time, you guys allegedly uniquely
have the great controversy theme, which
is supposed to be the antidote to
theological division, direct access to
the mind of
God. Yet, by saying that you guys are in
the mainstream proves that there are
there's division. There's other streams
in
Adventism. At the end of the day, you
guys just need to own up that you have
your own novel views on all this stuff
and defend it, not play word games and
semantics to try and make it seem like
you believe like we do, but you
don't. Again, Moon ends his paper that
Dr. Lake was paring by laying out all
the differences between what Christians
believe and what Adventists believe with
regards to the Trinity.
And that's why he had to appeal to
saying, "Well, she holds to a concept of
the Trinity, right? A unique view that
was informed by
supposed visions."
Gentlemen, we will continue responding
to their critique in a few weeks and
address the other clips from my
presentation that they play and listen
to and seek to respond to. As always,
may God richly bless you in the grace
and peace won by Jesus Christ and his
vicarious death on the cross for
sinners. Hallelujah.
[Music]